oh my god holy fucking shit okay okay i'm just i've been
like refreshing the auction page and like guys why is a
piece of paper at a thousand five hundred dollars it's
literally a piece of paper okay i'm gonna like sign like my
signature all over it but like it's just a piece of paper
how okay i'm gonna because like it's like you didn't put
your name on a nominate because i wanted it i like okay i'm
gonna say i love i love like the person who wrote like the
person who's bidding on it is like his name is that troll
boy is an irresponsible spender that's me what a fucking
legend holy fuck okay I'm gonna put your name up here right
now that's also a benefit for the benefit for being the
major bidder on this fucking paper your name your name goes
up on the screen right now
this guy this guy is like fucking that's him that's him this
guy is the one that's like currently um hard bidding on the
piece of paper he got outfitted by 25 dollars it's him holy
shit well well you already got outbid so i'm gonna time the
you're sorry bro you already got outbid so you're not on the
you're not on the screen anymore um but welcome everybody
i'm sorry like i had to talk about the auction for the paper
because that shit like blew my mind just seeing a thousand
five hundred dollars for a piece of paper like there's so
many other cool things in the auction but in the piece of
paper already got to a thousand five hundred dollars oh my
god i literally the market value for the thing is like one
dollar like it's a one i like up oh i got the sniper there's
a sniper in there too now his date my moment to shine oh my
god he's in the bidding war right now with that troll boy
all right for those who want to like like live watch watch
it live here's the here's the bidding for the piece of paper
for those who want to live watch the paper for being bit
it's a 2k holy fuck 2k anyway welcome everybody to um
hashtag dokey charity 2024 welcome everyone this is actually
uh really crazy um i i've always wanted to do a charity
stream longest time obviously like it has a lot of logistics
to go around um i want to give uh before i start talking
more about the serious time it's a little bit of serious
hour but uh before i want to talk about the charity thing i
want to give a giant shout out to little man um they've
worked incredibly hard um helping me with all of this um um
it's really it's actually crazy having um such a wonderful
assistant um helping me they've like they actually contacted
the foundation because at first tiltify um the auction thing
was actually a closed beta option and i didn't find out
about it until tuesday
i didn't realize it was because i thought that it was open
to everybody so on tuesday i getting ready to set up the
auction and then i looked at it and i was like wait a minute
it's closed beta and i was like freaking out i was like oh
my god guys i was like guys it's closed beta can you guys
like contact tiltafi and like tell them to grant me special
permission because i really wanted to access the auction and
um so little men um they helped they were in contacts with
tiltify staff and actually gave me the beta like the option
because like the auction is like reserved for like really
big streamers and stuff like that so like obviously like um
uh kitty cunerella for twitch uh did like a auction stream
as well as a lot of big streamers use the auction auction
feature on tiltify i didn't realize that it was reserved for
like really big streamers and events so i was just like fuck
I was just like, oh shit, okay, that, okay, I fucked up
there.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
So, um, so, um, like I said, a huge shout out to, uh, Little
Men for helping me get in touch with Tiltify, like Tiltify
people to give me the power to be able to host an auction.
but not only holy shit 16 000 oh my god okay to be fair okay
at first i didn't want to include the auction like the
auction fits into like the stretch goals but i decide that's
not really fucking fair and it's all for charity so like i'm
like you know what dokey be nice
give the dragoons give the dragoons a bone it's all for
charity I was like, okay, it's all for charity.
I will add the auction to the stretch goals as well.
Anyway, anyway, as I was saying, as I was saying, because of
that, then I realized the Brain and Behavior Research
Foundation was not on the list for auctions.
I was like, fuck.
because like when we got access to the auction i was like
okay uh little man was like all right you can do it you can
you can host auctions now and i was like yay and i was like
trying to do it and i was like wait where's brain and
behavior research foundation they're on tiltify but why
aren't they on the auction and then so then little man had
to like um get in touch with the brain and Behavior Research
Foundation organization and, you know, they actually had
like a context within the organization and they managed to,
the organization, the foundation managed to connect their
account to Tiltify to receive auction donations and
everything.
And that way, we were able to do that yesterday morning.
They actually, we have had everything set up at like five in
the morning on Friday, five in the morning on Friday.
And then on Friday, they worked on putting everything, all
the items and everything onto the auction list.
And they were the ones, Little Man was the ones that were in
contact with all the creators and all the creators and like
uh all the artists and all the wonderful creative people
around the world in coordinating all the items that are
going to be made uh for that was going to be made for this
auction so like i said a huge shout out to little man for
doing all of this it's really amazing i didn't have to i had
to do all this myself i had incredible help from little man
especially with contacting all the official people helping
me write all the business emails so I don't have to write
the I think that's like the best part I don't have to write
the business emails anymore like I think that's the part
that makes me the happiest because like you know writing
emails fucking suck I hate I hate I hate writing business
emails I hate writing like professional emails so like huge
shout out to Little Man for helping me write the
professional emails especially contacting like Tiltify and
contacting Tiltify and Brain and Behavior Research
Foundation.
Also I want to say thank you to everybody that applied to be
part of the auction.
It was incredibly difficult picking the creators because I
didn't want to have like Like, you know, like, fool, like
overwhelm everybody with a lot of items and everything.
So it was very difficult for me to pick, like, the items
that I want for the auction themselves.
So we actually got more than 200 applicants to be part of
the auction.
It was very, very difficult deciding, like, narrowing down
200 people um um little man actually helped out in helping
me narrow down the first round and in the second round i had
a hundred and like i think it was like 300 applicants i
believe it was around like 300 plus applicants and little
man narrowed it down to 180 for me and then from that 180 i
had to pick around 30 people um i don't actually know the
exact number i've picked but like from a hundred and eighty
I had to narrow it down even further to what we have now um
like I said it was incredibly difficult picking like uh the
people to uh to be part of this auction um and I want to say
thank you again to all everybody who are donating um the the
items um I told everybody that i was willing to uh chip in
and fund because i didn't i was there was like a paid
opportunity um but like also like a huge uh thank you to
those who uh wish to donate those profits to uh to charity
as well holy shit does someone donate 5 000 okay guys i need
a who would have fucked it guys give me so let me open my
tilt of fire real quick
holy fuck okay guys i've only been streaming for like 20
minutes guys i've only been streaming for 20 minutes oh my
god holy shit scott thank you for the 5k oh my god holy shit
thank you for the Okay, and yeah, anyway, fuck, I lost my
train of thought.
What was I saying?
What was I already lost my train of thought right now?
Holy shit.
Okay, um, anyway, anyway, like I was saying, it was
incredible.
It is just crazy because, like, I'm so happy to be able to
do something like this, to be able to do an auction for you
guys because like it allows me to work with so many talented
people.
All the items in the auction is one of a kind.
Two of kind.
I mean
mostly one of a kind.
Because I might have one too but like this doesn't matter.
Exclusive, one-of-a-kind.
Okay, okay, look, I will also own it one too, okay, but that
doesn't count.
I will also own, yes, I will have the piece of paper.
It's literally paper that I own.
Okay, but it will be one-of-a-kind for the dragoons.
me okay i will also own one as well so then we're matching
look i've had this argument already with my members okay
guys it means we will be matching is and that raises the
value okay guys us having matching items raises the value of
the item itself because we will be matching
It is limited edition paper!
It's my paper!
Who else would have touched the paper other than me?
Just think about it!
It literally has my fingerprints on...
Okay, wait, actually, I'm going to touch it with gloves.
I'm...
No, that's actually pretty bad if it has my fingerprints on
it.
I would be touching the paper with a...
glove so it would sadly not have my fingerprints on it it
will not have my fingerprints on the paper because i
realized that's a bit scary to give away
also um i am providing the money for shipping for all of
these items so do not worry if you're wherever you live
you're like oh my god would they be able to ship it there I
will be providing the money for the shipping to the creators
who will be shipping these products to you if you win the
auction um and also um even if like some of the items are
not made by me it's not coming from me I will be sending an
exclusive postcard to the each winner of the auction Each
winner of the auction will have will be able to receive a an
exclusive postcard made Just for this event How are we
already I it's crazy.
It's actually guys the the insane The insane amount of
support from from everybody like we were just starting I'm
just explaining the event right now and like I'm like
refreshing the like auction page and seeing everything's
been bid it's insane everything has been like already bid on
and uh and like oh my god there's so much money like i said
all the money goes directly towards um it goes directly
towards the foundation it doesn't go to me it goes directly
straight to the foundation like um the everything's already
connected to like their accounts so um they uh 100 receive
the money i don't receive anything for those who are like oh
my god don't care you're gonna receive any no i will not be
receiving any of the money it goes directly to them via
tiltify so um for those who want to know um what is the uh
the brain and behavior research foundation um they um they
are a charity that looks at providing funding into research
for cures and better treatment for uh mental illness so um
so like this is like a global thing it's not like uh it's
not like within one particular country it looks into uh
treatments and cures for um global treatment like basically
global research for mental illness and mental disorders so
um they provide majority of funding to because i know
there's a lot of charities that are going into like um like
salaries and programs and stuff like that and like all about
the the like the offices and stuff, but this, the reason why
I chose the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation is that
majority of the funding, like majority of the money that is
raised for this charity organization, for this foundation
goes directly to the research, um, and funding the research
and stuff.
And because I chose it because of also the global appeal,
because, you know, finding cures and finding treatments.
It's not like, it's not like, you know, centered around one
country.
If they find a cure or a better way to treat something for
mental illness, like people around the world will be able to
go for the medicine for it as well.
So it's not like, oh, you have to go to this country to be
able to receive it.
It is a cure.
It is a better treatment for people around the world and
that is why I chose this as um that's why I chose the brain
behavior research foundation for this particular event for
the one for the charity and also because people around the
world can also donate to this as well um and because I've
set up the YouTube thing the YouTube fundraising thing um
which is more about weight raising awareness raising
programs like a better support system for people with mental
illness with mental disorders on the YouTube one because it
was something I could do like quick and instantly and
something I wanted to do on YouTube for to because like you
know a lot of people eyes were on me and it was like the
thing I can do right away to help out and the mental health
America helps with that so mental health America is more so
about raising awareness and providing support structures and
programs.
Well, the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation is more
about trying to find the cure and finding better treatment.
And so that's why I felt like, you know, do have two of
these at around the same time is the best, like, way
regarding this.
So one, if you want to donate to the research, you can go
with the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation for the one
regarding mental health awareness.
the mental health america that you can donate via uh the
waiting room the one the mental of america is sadly only has
like specific countries can be able to donate via them uh
via the waiting room and that's why i made the tiltify for
like global donations so you don't have to worry about like
oh uh will will they be able to accept my donation because i
saw there's a lot of issue regarding it on the waiting room
was that a lot of countries were not able to donate to the
waiting room and That is why I decided to do this particular
stream and this auction to raise money for a second charity
as well Another 5k guys, I was doing a fucking TED talk Holy
shit, who is it?
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys Holy fuck.
This is insane.
This is actually Welcome to my TED talk.
That'll be 5k for ticket.
Oh my god.
Where are we at?
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Guys.
I don't know where that hot sauce is.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's keep laughing to get nothing and stop.
Oh my.
How much did we like?
Okay.
What is like.
How much have we made from the office?
alone How much how much did we make from the awk guys?
I need where's my where's my human calculators guys How much
how much did we make on the auction alone?
This is all right, where's the piece of it's at 4k?
I swear it What's some more?
Damn troll boy gave up Holy shit
It went to 4K and then that troll boy was like, I can't man,
bro.
It's a piece of paper
Oh my god Okay, all right, I actually I have he changed to
the keyboard Okay, that troll boy, but I want that keyboard
because oh shit full name natural point swap to the keyboard
and the paper was just too expensive man okay okay that's
pretty funny that's pretty funny that you swap to the you
swap to the fucking keyboard now all right what's your name
where is it where did when when did you last bit i'm trying
to find your full name what's your full name paste your I
like how I like how one of the names for the cookies is
we'll learn to bake cookies like they're buying the cookie
cutter and they're like I will learn to bake cookies for
that cookie cutter don't stream snip that troll boy but now
I want a keyboard because the paper is too damn expensive
Okay, who's getting him?
Okay, that one is good.
That one's actually really good.
I actually like that.
Here you go.
You get to be on the stream until somebody snipes you, and
then you're off the screen.
And then you're off the screen again.
You're on the screen again.
Jesus Christ.
Also, for those who are worried, like, if the winning bid is
unable to pay for the item, it will go automatically go
towards the second winner.
You will have, like, around, I think, like, one to two days
to pay for the item.
If you're unable to, it will go towards the second winning,
like, the second winner.
So, just to be, like, there is, like, a backup, like, a plan
B, if that happens, type deal.
Why bid when you can't pay?
Because, like, they thought they had the...
I would assume they thought they had the money.
and then suddenly they're like wow the paper went to four
thousand dollars let's see what's on my bank account oh hey
four thousand like three thousand nine hundred dollars
like i feel like i feel like you know nobody would expect
that you know nobody would expect that to
Anyway, yeah, and also, emergencies can happen, obviously.
Oh, my God.
All right.
So, so, okay.
Let me go through each of the items, as well as the creator
who go into detail of each of the...
It's like, what are those, like, infomercial?
All right, welcome to Doki Bird's infomercial time.
I'm sorry that we do not have an elder.
couple who's gonna fall and can't get up or like not be able
to do something correctly and then I'll be like and then
it'll be like black and white and then the X is like have
you ever wanted to do this anyway welcome to the Doki bird
infomercial for charity I will be introducing each oh almost
to the hot oh my gosh okay is my parents still here are they
are they I don't think They went out for lunch yet.
Alright.
How many of you have hot sauce?
Oh, hola, that girl.
Hey, yo.
Okay.
Hey.
Alright.
My mom's getting the hot sauce now.
She was like, you need it now?
I was like, yeah.
He's like, We're there?
Yeah, we're...
We're there.
We're fucking there.
What the fuck?
How do we get there?
It's been 30 already!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna look through which one is it.
Whoa!
Alright.
This one.
The last dab experience.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
It's called the last dab experience.
We're going to over 91% pepper.
It's apparently 2 million SHU.
I will show it later.
We will do this after I talk about it.
After I talk about the charity, about the auction items,
guys, there's other stuff I want to talk about before we get
to the hot sauce.
There's so many things I haven't done on the stretch clothes
yet.
I haven't even, like, talked about the stretch.
We haven't gone to any of the actual content of the charity
event.
What I've been talking about is just like monitoring what
the fuck is going on Oh my god, wait, I love this I love
like how they're like fighting so hard right now Over the
piece of paper Over the piece of keyboard Okay, I like this
Um So it's between these two people right now um these two
people are are fighting it out for the keyboard this is not
the paper this is for the keyboard now i honestly will not
be surprised if troll boy is gonna like bounce in between
like different auction items just to win something i will
not be surprised anyway um anyway does any as i was saying
does anyone know how far we've raised Currently for the
auction itself chat.
I'm actually curious.
How far have we currently Raised from just like overall a
52,000?
Oh my god What?
We made 52,000 from the auction alone By the way, the
auction itself will be 24 hours um so it's going to close
tomorrow at uh it's gonna close tomorrow at um i believe 12
p.m psc so it'll give time for those around the world to be
able to bid because i know it's like super fucking early
right now in asia like it's like five or six a.m over there
so because of that we are making sure the auction um gives
enough time for a bunch of uh dragoons from around the world
to on it so you know they don't have to wake up super early
and to stay up for the rest of the day to like snipe each
other anyway i can finally introduce the items okay all
right i will finally be able to introduce the items of which
that is going to be part of the auction let me find the
folder um i was more prepared earlier but now i'm like whoa
Anyway, the first item that I'll be talking about, okay, I'm
going to refresh.
I'm just going to go by order from the, I'm going to go by
order from the site itself.
So, the first item is the, we have like several amazing
sculptures and figure makers, like I said, this is all like
one of a kind.
to the dragons.
Some might say it's two of a kind because I will also own
one.
But let's all just agree that it is one of a kind.
It will never be released.
Re-released.
You will own.
It's one plus one equals one.
One plus one equals one.
By the way, guys.
so um quick maths right there anyway anyway as i was saying
only one in public circulation yes i like that only one in
public circulation so as i was saying um the first item on
the list is um um is a custom doki sculpture uh by exeon
figures i don't know I'm so sorry if like I am
mispronouncing uh your name because I'm very bad at that so
this is the um this is not the actual figure itself um this
is an example of of what they can do so you will have input
on the sculpture itself um in the design but uh this is an
example of the type of sculptures and sculpting they can do
um they can give you two options for this obviously one is
the file to print your own sculpture like 3d print your own
sculpture if you do have a 3d printer and painted it
yourself or the creator of the sculpture a custom doki
sculpture yes yes yes it's bay but like it's the example
they have because you By winning this auction, you can have
your input.
You can have your input on how it would look like.
And basically, the second option is that they can make an
unpainted resin version of...
They can make an unpainted resin version of the...
sculpture themselves and it will be shipped to you so you
can like paint it yourself and everything but the the it's
but it's also made of resin so it is so um so obviously it
is very high quality uh and everything um what else in my
what else do i want to talk about um like i said each
auction Each auction winner will be sent an exclusive
postcard.
So everything, even if it's like something regarding no
physical item, you will also be sent the postcard.
An exclusive signed postcard from me.
So that is number one.
It is a custom Doki sculpture.
Number two.
The second item that I'll be showing is...
Wow!
A one-of-a-kind custom Doki Bird themed PC.
This is not just a PC case.
It will also be a customized, fully built PC.
So it's not just a case, by the way.
I know some people were wondering if it's like just a PC
case or not, but it will also be a Fully customized PC that
fits around like me that would be like around my color
scheme and everything um, so this is by Celeste Fleur um It
was valued at three thousand five hundred like including the
PC parts and everything um and now it's at six thousand a
hundred Wow so like the PC parts itself was um was going was
um 3,500, including the customization.
This is not from Hyatt.
This is actually from a user named Celeste Fleur, who is
using a Hyatt case, just so you guys know.
I just wanted to clarify for those who are confused.
This is actually just using a Hyatt case.
So it will be, so it's valued at 3,500.
um including the parts itself and like the decorations and
everything um and yeah so it's not just a case i know a lot
of people are confused that it was just going to be the case
itself but no it is a fully custom like fully made custom pc
all right item number three the cookie cutters these are so
cute i love these are actually so cute oh my god all right
anyway So, the cookie cutters.
Item number three from Risu.
So, there are multiple cookie cutters.
There's multiple styles.
But each auction item that you bid on will come with two
cookie cutters.
One will be my face.
And the other one will be a dragoon.
So it is basically your pick on whether...
Which you want the dragoon to have a knife or do you want
the dragoon with no knife the chunky goons So this is item
three to like insert Like three to four five six seven item
three to seven the different expressions of cookie cutters
And I think it's very very fucking cute and I love how I
love how like one of them is like I will learn how to bake
cookies I love the fucking You guys are so creative Like I
like Someone that's like Never baked cookies in my life And
I will drop an entire paycheck For this The one guy's like I
never baked cookies in my life But I need this This is now
The next This is my life now I will learn how to bake all
the cookies If I have this cookie cutter We Oh my god,
there's another guy that's like I just want something for
$500.
I only have $500, please.
I just Please, I need this exclusive, exclusive post guide.
Anything that's under $500, please.
Anyway, that is item three to four, five, six.
I'm really bad at count three to seven all right next item
on the list um the next item on the list all right the next
item on the list is a I know this is not me I know that is
uh I know that is Sakura Miku Hatsune I know that guys but
this is um this is an example of the oh my god the next The
nice next item is Hatsune Miku?
Doki, I did not realize you were Hatsune Miku.
Is that Doki but pink?
Anyway.
Anyway, the next item on the list is a custom Doki sign
print from this artist.
This artist's name is, I'm so sorry, I'm definitely going to
butcher your name.
um uh aerosol uh aerosol um my mod would be linking their
twitter um their twitter in chat um so this you can see the
art style i will be i will be printing it don't worry it's
gonna be a high quality print do not worry do not worry it's
not gonna be like paper i mean it's paper but it will be
like nice paper it'll be very nice paper okay guys
it's not gonna be you know like when you're at anime
conventions and then uh you know like okay so like you know
like at a conventions where you're buying like anime prints
it's gonna be like that but signed okay
At least I was like, I love paper.
I love paper.
Like 4.4k.
Nice.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know.
It would be that nice.
But it would be nice.
It would be pretty good.
Really nice colors too.
I will make sure.
It would be very good colors.
Like the best quality type of colors.
And the best quality type of paper.
That you can get.
And I will be signing it.
So it will be a Tokyo.
sign print from this artist um beautiful art style um um
really lovely colors and everything uh so this is an example
of their art style like everyone's like it's on paper fuck
yeah
oh my god don't you don't need to say anything more it's on
paper that's all i need to know all right anyway Next item
on the list.
Let me see if I could find the picture they've sent us.
All right.
The next item on the list.
Okay, this is going to take up, like, my face real fast.
Okay, here we go.
I never thought I could hang this low.
All right, the next item on the list.
It is a hardcover sticker book.
book with three four exclusive stickers to include in your
collection look guys it's multiple papers
guys it's not just one paper it's multiple papers in a book
okay that's like come on that's like i don't even know uh 75
sheets of paper guys 75 five sheets of paper in one, but
it's not signed.
Okay.
You will get an exclusive signed postcard, okay?
That's almost like it was signed.
Anyway.
Anyway, it's more than one.
Anyway, this next item from Rimon, I was very surprised when
Rimon wanted to the charity auction because I actually very
heavily admire Riri stuff ever since like I saw them at
artist alley they won't know who I am it's been years I
actually own multiple items from Riri like for years because
like they are like they've been like doing artist alley for
like a really really long time so like actually i've like
seen them at convention and i've actually they will never
know they'll never know who it was so i've actually heavily
admiring me because i've actually owned several um of their
i like uh merch that they've made um in artist alleys and uh
so yeah i'm really really happy that they're part of the
charity auction
Bro, it wasn't even four years ago.
It might be like eight years ago.
They've been like, they've been doing artist alley and like
selling stuff online for so long.
Like it wouldn't even be four years, maybe like eight.
Maybe like eight years ago.
Like they are like a veteran to artist alley and
conventions.
Okay.
And then I like, I will not be surprised if Ryo was like, I
have not been selling for eight years.
Like,
And before they come in, it caught me.
I was like, Doki, I have not been selling for eight years.
That is not true.
Okay.
Well, it felt like eight years, okay?
It felt like eight years.
Anyway, it is a sticker book with exclusive stickers.
Obviously, I believe the stickers will be based around me.
Unless they're random stickers, but I think it's healthy to
assume it's gonna be about me You're right.
I'm a veteran a hard and I do it I do it I was like eight
years does feel a really long time though So like maybe it
wasn't eight years, but I knew I just know that I was I
bought something from her Maybe eight years ago
anyway as i was saying so yeah this is gonna be a sticker
book yay with 75 sheets of paper that's a lot of paper guys
it is a lot all right next item next item on on the list
let's see what is where is it where where is the where is
the uh okay this one is is whoa this one is a big one We can
see the beautiful R.
The next one on the list.
A custom signed metal poster.
I will be signing these.
I believe.
Because it says sign.
Alright.
This is not just regular paper.
Oh my gosh.
This is.
Okay I'm gonna.
I can't.
Okay.
It is not just regular paper, but metal paper.
Well, look, there is a tier list.
Metal paper, sticker paper, A4 paper.
So, that one is, this is going to be a signed.
It's going to be shiny, okay?
It is going to be shiny.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It's gonna be It's gonna be metal paper And the artist is
Paranoia, WWW And so Obviously it is your character here So
they will be drawing you And me together And I need to read
this whole thing Sorry I didn't read the So you choose one
of the three poses that they've given uh given you to choose
from if you win the auction and obviously it says like what
they can and can't draw so there are like stuff you can't do
and stuff you can do um and then also their beautiful art
style their art style is so fucking pretty oh my god it's
actually gorgeous and that is the other next item next item
on the list after that oh we're in the plushy territory now
i think i think we might go back to like non-plushy areas
too um let's see where is the where the where did i put the
okay here you go next item on the list it's gonna be a
plushy i also want to love about like all of the um creators
that are um that is that everybody chose a different outfit.
A lot of people chose different outfits.
It's not just one outfit.
Obviously, I had many, many outfits.
So it's really nice because it's like all different outfits
are represented in the auction.
So there's like a particular dokey fashion that you like.
Maybe you'll find it in one of the auctions.
Anyway, so this is by Rimi Plushy.
It is 36 inches sitting.
That is a really big plushie.
I'm just going to say, like, 36 inches for a plushie is
pretty tall.
It is very tall.
Yes, this is by Rumi Plushie, your very own exclusive,
one-of-a-kind in public circulation plushie for you to own.
Is that three feet?
Oh, my, okay, no.
Is that actually three feet?
Sorry, I can't count in inches.
I use feet.
Oh my god.
That is it.
Three feet is a lot, actually.
Holy shit.
Alright, that is one of the plushies that's going to be in
the auction.
Next item.
Alright, the next item is actually very interesting.
product um I was at first when uh little man uh because
little man made me an excel sheet of um of like all the
people that um applied that got through the first round um
and when I saw this I was like what the fuck is in like I
don't even remember what they wrote oh I am yeah I was like
what the fuck is an i that is not paper what the fuck look
everybody will have paper in the end because everyone's
gonna be sent a fucking uh postcard anyway so i was like
what is it what's it i was so confused i was actually
incredibly confused and then i had to like google google it
and i was like oh it said yeah an in-ear monitor i was like
like that's how someone was like That's a four paper right
there.
Anyway, it will be a one of a kind in public circulation.
Doki Bird.
I-E-M from Kutari Audio.
So it's like fancy earphones.
So I love to show you guys the designs they sent me.
Because I have to look at pictures to actually realize like
what is that?
I'm sorry I'm not good with like technical stuff guys I'm
not good with like technology okay to an extent I am okay
with technology to an extent but like I was so confused
because I didn't know what the fuck IEM was so this would be
like the concept that they've like given us um so you can
Oshimark and my colors and everything.
So you can have like, you know, like I said, one of a kind
in public circulation.
Typical V2.
Yes, I get all my knowledge from other people.
So this is like the concept, the concept render of what it
will look like.
And then they also sent like a box of like the packaging and
everything.
So there's actually, it will also come with like a sticker,
an exclusive sticker made for it as well.
As well as there's like a lot of things going on with it.
So there's also gonna be like exclusive box art and stuff.
That package paper.
There's your paper.
There it is.
The paper.
gonna be exclusive packaging and everything um as well as
here like the artists that would be a part of it so um so
like sticker artists so yours gonna be your exclusive
sticker art stickers as well as box art so here are the
credits of every everybody that is part of the um of the iem
um guys i swear to god how much has the a fort paper gone
for now i swear to god port palace in 400 okay they stopped
37 minutes ago okay that is very reassuring
that is very reassuring that that the war has stopped now
a lot better okay uh anyway next item on the list this is
very this is an interesting one um it's really really cute
so this is a sterling silver dragon necklace it is made from
sterling sticker uh it is from uh katako katako taco um And
it is a full-on necklace pendant.
I believe it also includes a chain for it as well.
So you got to have your chunky goon with you on your neck at
all times.
Yeah, sterling silver too.
Their work is absolutely beautiful.
I remember looking at their portfolio for everything.
stuff too like I'll show you guys I'll give like a shout out
to their Etsy like look at their the stuff they have made as
well it's actually crazy like the the the Mario star pendant
and uh it's actually really well done like um the stuff
they've made on their Etsy store um so uh huge shout out to
their work um uh was beautiful to see their portfolio uh but
yes the sterling silver chunky um is the the this item all
right the next one is although i do have a doki makura in my
official shop you can have a chance to own an exclusive
one-of-a-kind in public circulation doki makura
I would admit, it's sexier than anything I've ever seen.
This has to be so fucking high.
I was like, I was like, we're about to get banned, Doki, no,
don't show this to the public.
anyway so um this is by keen biscuit um like i said one of a
kind doki makura um it's just so fucking hot that only one
can be made and owned at all times so i hope whoever whoever
wins this is a very lucky individual in accurate talking.
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
Okay.
Alright, so anyway, that is what that is this item in the
auction.
Got me It's life size.
Yes, it is life size.
It is very accurate to how I actually am proportional.
It's all ways.
Also the butt too.
Also the butt.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
Yeah, it's automatically accurate.
The anatomy is very accurate.
All right, anyway.
Anyway, that is this item in the auction.
All right, next up.
Next up.
This is not a physical item.
So there is no picture.
There is no picture.
This is not a physical item.
This is basically, I will collab with an indie or streamer
of your choice.
So I'm just going to read out the description, but
basically, if you win this auction, you can pick an indie
VTuber or like a streamer of your choice, who is your
favorite streamer, and you want to give them like a big
break, you want to have more eyes on them, and I will try to
reach out to them for a collab.
Obviously, it is up to their choice if they wish to collab
with me.
And if they do decline, obviously you'll have to give me a
plan B on who to reach out after.
So I decided to do this to maybe, like, if you want to give,
like, a chance to one of your favorite streamers who might
not be big in the streaming community and have a chance to
have a lot of eyes on them.
And be able to maybe have this, like, a big break for them
as well.
So that is one of the, this is the one, the non-physical
items.
Non-physical items that I'm giving.
But yeah, anyway, next item on the list is also a
non-physical item.
Pick a game for me to stream.
So if there is a game that you've always wanted me to
stream, but I chose to ignore you.
I will not be able to ignore you anymore by winning this
auction except for Visage because that is a stretch goal so
by winning this auction for pick a game for me to stream you
can forced me to stream your favorite game to completion on
stream.
So, it will not be to 100%.
It will be to, like, the end of the story.
And that is within TOS, obviously.
Like, so I can stream it.
And, like, there is no MMOs.
MMOs are not allowed.
Just so you guys are wondering.
MMOs are not allowed by winning this because There's no way
to fucking complete MMOs
But I will stream it to completion Obviously if you try to
be like super cheeky And be like Oh my god What about
Destiny 2 Because there's no end to Destiny 2 Because they
will keep releasing missions And like stories and DLCs That
is not allowed I can like Alright you can't be cheeky on
this You can't I'm giving you a chance to be like play an
RPG game like a JRPG game because I choose not to play JRPG
games because I know I know that like for me like JRPGs and
me just do not mix very well I haven't found one that I
actually enjoyed so this is your chance to force me if you
win the bid to force me to stream a JRPG Especially when
JRPGs are like fucking 100 plus hour fucking streams, even
if you're speed running to the end.
But yeah, if you win the auction, obviously.
Anyway, next item on the list.
It is.
The piece of paper.
This is the next item on the list.
It is your fucking A4 paper where I will sign.
I will cover it up with my sign.
How did that go in up?
Three minutes ago?
You haven't been bidding for like one hour that you came
back?
This person hasn't bid for an hour?
And then, like, they're like, this is it.
This is my time to shine now.
No.
And then, I'm waiting for...
Anyway, they just, like, showed up.
They literally stopped bidding when it was at $3,000.
They stopped at $3,000.
And then they had to go to the pick.
Sorry, they had to make, like, a quick deposit real quick,
you know?
They had to do some quick, like...
a quick loan real quick to be able to keep going anyway
anyway so this piece yes it's not just a piece of paper I
literally wrote that's gonna be a piece of paper covered
with my signature so I'll be like writing my signature on it
um anyway anyway so it's not just a pure white paper I will
have i would i would taint it with my signature that's why
the paper is now 10k
so anyway that is that item on on the list next item on the
list is a private one-to-one gaming session with me of any
game of your choice so it will go maximum three hours
maximum because like i don't know if you suddenly pick like
a two hour game like what the so um we will be setting if
you win this obviously if you win this okay it's gonna be
multiplayer you can't be like oh my gosh i want a private
one-to-one gaming session with do i'm gonna make her play
this that doesn't that's not how it works it's a multiplayer
game a multiplayer game guys but it is going to be a private
session um three hours maximum um and why wouldn't you spend
with uh uh mr man or either little man and i will be like
coordinating schedule to figure out like it'll be on one of
my rest days obviously it'll be on one of my rest days and
we will play together the private session it won't be
streamed or anything it'll be like a one-to-one session, uh,
for charity.
Uh, but yeah, that is that, that item.
How many more do we have?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, ten, 11, 12,
34, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19.
Oh my gosh, we got 20.
Sorry, this has to be the longest ad session ever.
That's great, because, and I don't have to, I don't have to
fucking worry about eating the hot sauce yet.
I have 20 more items before I get to eat the hot sauce.
Alright.
Anyway.
The 24 hour unskippable ad.
That's how I like my ads.
Unskippable.
No plugin can save you.
Weird.
Fucking no ad blocker plugin can save you now.
Alright.
Next item on the list.
Let me grab the picture for this one where'd i put it okay
auction photos uh also shout out to little man for compiling
all the photos for me uh into like one folder thank you i
love it uh next item on the list is a drag i'm gonna
mispronounce like what it's called a dragon amigurumi so bye
uh hey it's j um so you get to have a chance to win two uh
dragon crochet plushies one wears a shirt they're not naked
they have a shirt on so this is your chance to win both of
them it's not just one but two of them as well so uh so this
is incredibly cute i love crew crochet is so fucking hard.
I was like watching a video on like, what was it called?
Woobles?
Apparently this like viral TikTok TikTok like crochet kit or
something called the Woobles or something.
It's like the Wiggles, but like I guess less Australian.
Wait, are they New Zealand?
I can't.
I'm sorry, Australians, New Zealanders.
I get you guys confused which one is which.
Like what?
I mean, I don't get the country confused.
I get like who's from where?
Like, like, like the accents are a little bit similar so
like i i don't remember if like if there's like a famous
actor i'd be like are you new zealand or australian i i
sometimes forget oh anyway but anyway um i was like watching
a video on like wobble kid or whatever like like some arts
and crafts youtuber that um that was like introducing the
wobbles and it's some like Royal crochet kit and they were
like I have never done crochet before so we're gonna see if
it is beginner friendly and I was like what the fuck let's
just like watch it like this is beginner friendly I was just
like holy fuck like oh my god I cannot do arts and crafts
arts and crafts is like I can't I don't have like first off
I don't think I have the page the last time I had the
patience for arts and crafts stuff is when I think this is
like I don't know this is like a this is an Asian thing like
when you're a kid but there's these like arts and crafts
where you can fold the paper into these like triangle pieces
um but you draw that's art drawing is just art there's no
crafting in there's no there's no crafting is just art
anyway anyway it's not I mean it's Not really origami.
I'm not talking about origami.
But, like, it's like using origami to make something.
But, like, it's basically you make these little triangle
things.
And then you piece these triangle things together into a
structure.
Um, and I used to do that, um, as a kid.
Like, I would follow a lot of these, like, triangles.
And then it would be like, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop.
And then there's Doraimo.
I have one.
Because they always sell them at Daiso.
I remember as a kid They always had these kids at Daiso And
then I would buy like the hamster I have the hamster one And
then I had like Doraemon And then I did that I did that as a
kid Is that what it's called?
The Tandgram But yeah that was like the extent of my
crafting I also did like plushie making For school But like
it was It was a bit of a mess.
It was a bit of a mess.
Holy shit.
We're $48,000?
Oh my.
Don't worry.
I have a list of stretch goals just in case this happened.
I was like a little bit.
I was like, okay.
Thinking up stretch goals is like one of the hardest,
honestly, one of the hardest things ever.
Because I'm like, what the fuck do people want?
Like I was just like, what the fuck do people want?
what do you want so I had like an huge list of things anyway
after I introduce all the auction items I'll talk about the
stretch goals with which we've practically mostly hit
already like we're ready mostly there on the ones that are
officially on the stretch goals anyway the next item it is
not a physical pick the next official doki outfit so what
that means is that you get to you get to help pick decide
the theme and help design like and give your input give your
input on on on what my next official outfit is going to be
the one after you know not this not after this but like
after the other way so um so obviously it has to be within
tos youtube twitch friendly for streaming so i can actually
wear it on stream so so by winning this auction you can be
part of the process and part of like deciding like you know
we'll be sending you like artwork concept art and get to
decide like pick between the concept art and give input on
what you want included in the concept art obviously you're
not going to be paying for the the fucking outfit i will be
paying for the outfit so you don't have to worry about like
paying for charity and also the outfit itself like the
illustration for the outfit do not worry i will be paying
for the skin suit being made like with the the rigging and
everything do not worry i will be paying for the laundry of
the skin suit and the crafting of the skin suit.
So you don't have to worry about that.
You get to be part of the process.
So that is okay.
So that's all you have to pay after the auction.
Next item on the list is a...
Okay, let me put it up on the screen.
Let me see if I find the right picture.
So the next item...
It's not this piece of paper.
It's a concept art.
The next item is a dragon wood carving.
This is the concept art of the wood carving itself.
So they have, they've actually sent in multiple like stuff
they've done in the past.
So here is like something they've, oh my god, this fucking
picture is ginormous.
So this is like a proof of something they've actually done
before.
And it's made of trees.
So it's almost like paper.
It's the same material.
It's the same fucking material.
So this is like one of the things they've done in the past.
So it's a full wood carving that they've carved themselves.
But instead of that, you would get a dragon.
You would get dragon.
And you can choose between different dragon types.
Like, you know, someone you can add an egg at the bottom
too.
Like, you know, like I said, concept art is subjected to
change, and, um, it is by, uh, Chin, I'm sorry, I, Chin-09
is the artist.
I have to, like, look at it for a second and be like, how do
I pronounce it?
Chin?
I guess there's a one?
it so so um so this is the next item okay next letter item
on the list we're almost there we're like okay one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen we're 17 we might sorry i keep
getting distracted and i keep zatsudani when i'm I've not
got to any part of the auction.
Like, we're still stuck in the auction part of it.
I apologize.
We're still introducing the auction.
We will get there soon.
I hope you're still entertained.
I hope you're still entertained while we're still on the
auction.
It's not stalling!
I'm literally introducing the items!
I like how someone's like, stop apologizing, explain faster!
Stop apologizing!
Okay, anyway.
Next item on the list.
I need to find the...
Okay, here we go.
Another!
Okay, whoa, this is a giant...
Oh, my God, that's a big-ass tomato.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
okay i need to resize this real fast next item it is another
signed print this is a work in progress um it is by uh cow
moon uh on twitter and uh like like you said this is a uh
this is going to be a signed print um sent uh by me uh drawn
by this illustrator um look at All these fucking tomatoes.
Who the fuck are they?
And why are they not eaten yet?
I can't believe it.
Who let these guys out their cage?
Who let them out?
It's not dinner time yet.
All right.
And anyway, this is another sign print.
Another sign print that you can win.
Next up is also another sign print.
If I can find it.
It is landscape style this time!
Alright, this one is by Shows 140.
This is going to be another sign print.
Obviously, this is a concept art.
So, it will be...
Oh, my God.
We're at fucking 50k already?
Oh, okay, let me...
Alright, guys.
Alright.
you know what all right the next stretch goes i'm just gonna
let you guys pick on the list because like i i can't think i
have a giant list of like what to do afterwards so you guys
can pick on the list afterwards after each goal we hit let
me all right sorry little intermission we gotta fix this now
because we made it past holy fuck we already made it past
the dk oh my god Thank you, everybody.
This is...
Oh, my God.
I can't believe we already made it past...
50k.
That's...
Oh, my God, guys.
I mean, that's actually crazy.
Oh, oh, my God.
It's only been an hour!
We raised so much!
I mean, if we count the charity...
We've made, like, if we count the auction...
any fundraising from like the one on the youtube waiting
room this it's like we've we've like raised like we've
raised like a hundred and fifty thousand dollars technically
if you think about it because we also have the one from the
youtube charity and then the auction itself so we've already
made a hundred and fifty k thousand that's a lot of money
that's oh my god it's just insane oh my god all right let me
uh put like the incentive okay where the fuck uh incentives
okay milestone all right add milestone okay 60 000 um chat
chooses from list answer all of them is just gonna be chat
chooses from list chat chooses from list okay wait not
visage
All right, you guys want to know when we hit massage?
When you guys get massage?
Okay, I'll let you know.
You guys get massage at, okay, $400,000.
You know what?
Okay, you guys want to know?
All right, here, this is the only way you'll get massage to
complete shit.
This is the only way you'll ever get massage.
For those who keep demanding, Visage Visage to end of story
$400,000 That's fucking right
It's like I like how like It's like 60k Chat chooses from
list Not Visage 400k Totally Visage
it's not a scam how is this a scam it's you cannot say a
charity is a scam you cannot say that you cannot say charity
that's fucked up man hey don't worry I do have other
reasonable goals um i i will play elden ring until for one
stream at 300 see this is reasonable guys that's so fucking
reasonable i'll play elden ring for one stream um 300k if
you want me to finish that's 400k that's 500k hey wait a
second okay i'll play eleanor for one stream and kill two
bosses okay i'll kill two bosses and kill two boss okay
defeat defeat defeat two boss okay i i couldn't i can like
put the full Um, I can't, I'll kill me right, right BOS
because like I ran out of space, so, uh, I, I, I ran out of
space, so it's just BOS, sorry, look, I, I'm character
limitations, character limitations is hard, okay, all right,
when do we stop solid, I'm putting this, I'm putting this
fucking, the stretch goals right now for us, all right, at
100k, I will play Brood War, I will play brood war.
There we go.
Bam.
Easy.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, we'll figure out the other stretch goals later.
We'll figure out the other ones later.
These are like the, these are like the main goals to strive
for.
Like the main ones.
It's not an ad.
I'm actually trying to figure out the stretch goals right
now.
Okay, 200.
Okay, 150k.
I will Pokemon Smash or Pass.
Pokemon Smash or Pass.
200k.
There we go.
You can judge my fucking taste in Pokemon.
200k.
There we go.
Look, we have 100, 200, 300, 4.
We'll figure out the other stretch goals later, okay?
This has been a long ad.
We have, like, the general ones yet now.
We have, like, the general idea of what we want for now.
all right anyway where was i on this long ad campaign all
right okay next up next up look we still have fucking 16
more items to go through next up this is so cute i actually
own a clay puff figure a long um that was made like three
years ago three to four years ago um obviously you know the
one I own was like three to four years ago clay puff figure
and now she's like even better they're like a better they're
like um um you know they have three to four years experience
now um and um this is a figure of me being eeppy and this is
the I bet I think like the base of it on the on the end and
uh but yeah it's so fucking cute this is by clay puff uh and
honestly it's made of polymer clay and acrylic uh so it's a
doki themed standee so it'll just be there it'll just be
like looking at you me ep and looking at you while sleeping
me me me me me me um it's actually already finished so these
are one of the items that will be sent out instant not
instantly but around march 15th um so these are items that
are already finished and you can receive it uh right away
well not right away but like you know like fast enough you
know
uh but yes that is uh the sculpture from clay puff all right
next up oh this one this one is um this one will be i think
um you guys would really like uh this is a next one is a
another sculpture let me see if i can fucking pull it up so
i will give you guys the what they've done in the past so
they have sculpted this in the past this is going they are
this is from juicy buns and this is like their design like
this is a one of the works they've done in the past and
basically that's not me but they will make a version that's
me like just so you guys know I know that's not me this is a
sample but the actual sculpture will look like this just so
you guys know the actual sculpture that's not you because
that's the other this is what the
to be a high quality resin and it'll be sent to Japan to be
professionally painted and then sent to you.
So it's a one of a kind in public circulation.
Disclaimer.
In public circulation.
A one of a kind.
Basically resin figure that is professionally painted by a
painter in Japan.
um and it will be sent out by end of may um so holy shit
it's at six thousand okay anyway anyway i didn't even
realize how many bids it has now oh my god okay i okay
anyway and anyway it is at six thousand three hundred at the
moment um but i think it's actually really fucking cool that
um it's actually gonna be sent to to to someone it's not
like an unpainted resin figure it's gonna be sent to
somebody in japan to fully paint it out and everything so
it's like a professional like figure in general like it's
actually a figure so that's like the really cool thing about
this all right next up next up all right The next work.
Oh, hey, I got my chicken.
It's been an hour and 30 minutes.
Thank God I have it.
Who just gave me my chicken.
I'm laughing because I am scared.
I'm laughing because I'm scared right now.
Anyway, I will show you guys like stuff they've done in the
past.
um so uh well this is not me just so you guys know this is
not me this is an example of what they've done in the past
so um basically uh it is a cut out art in an acrylic block
so it will look like uh it will look like this so it'll be
like in a professional block uh of the artwork and uh false
average i'm getting to it guys i am getting to it but this
is by um jqhn herald i i'm sorry i'm sorry i pronounced the
name is it's jqhn i which i assume john i assume i assume
it's john but it's with a q Um, so, this is the concept art
that they gave us, uh, where is it?
Where is it?
So, this is what the concept art would look like.
Um, it's not this.
This is a concept.
Just so you guys know, it's not, this is not what's being
sent to you.
This is a concept art.
This is not the $900 thing you're bidding on.
This is a concept.
or what it would look like so um and it'll be in this
acrylic block uh and this is from john uh on twitter uh well
not just john it's like john harold but like i'll just call
him john all right next item it's another plushie another
plushie yeah yeah i really do like how all of them are like
different outfits it's so cute like it's like which dokey
bird do you want to have in your collection which one
this item dokey plushie number two so um this one is by
plush mayhem and um oh their uh their previous works are
incredibly adorable let me show you guys what they've sent
to us uh if i have it Wait, do I have one?
Oh, wait, I don't.
Wait, I do.
I do.
Okay, I do.
I actually do.
Here we go.
This is some of the stuff they've done in the past, like
their style and everything.
So this is basically, like I said, like, you had made
plushie.
And it is it is by Plush Mayhem.
So this is what they've done in the past.
But instead of that bitch, I'm sorry, she's I'm not a bitch.
I don't even know who she is.
Okay.
It's a term of endearment.
It will look like this.
It will...
Look, it's a term of... If I call you a bitch, it's like a
nice thing.
Okay.
Like, wait, don't call your friends...
Bitch?
Like, what's up, bitch?
Okay.
anyway um next up on the list um i am nice what do you mean
you can't say that when i'm literally doing a charity stream
i am exempt from that like for the day for today i am nice
this is like my my nice day this is actually my nice day um
anyway anyway
toxic positivity okay uh i am nice she yells out and screams
to chat anyway the next item the next item on the list this
one i'm actually really really excited about i've talked
about this before on stream um but i'll be giving us a
sample what they've done like this is not this is not the
one that's being uh being auctioned off but it's a sample of
the past so oh my gosh this photo is huge okay all right
this is a custom uh ball jointed doll is 16 inches and it
will that's not the one that's being sold it's gonna be of
me that's not me by the way i don't know if you notice i
think i know it's hard to tell i know it's almost the same
but this is by doll's jewel or like moonlight jewel um i am
a huge fan of custom doll making um and it would be a joki
version a joki bird version um i am incredible i i love
custom ball jointed dolls in general i love like watching
like doll customization like i i like watched a lot of like
doll lifeo in the past um she's like one of my guilty
pleasure youtubers uh i love that when they do like they
customize like monster high dolls and stuff like that it's
so interesting to watch i've actually like before um like
five years ago i was like actually looking to commission a
dokey ball jointed doll for myself like five years ago i
remember just looking up doll customizers those who like
customize monster and high dolls and everything and um and i
recently started watching moonlight jewel because they've
done a lot of like a lot of customization similar doll
customization and it's honestly really interesting to watch
because it's like very creative what they do and it's like
um i feel like doll customization is very like you know it's
like very difficult to do because you gotta know how to make
clothes you gotta know how to customize like dolls in
general like and then know how to like draw on the eyes
sometimes or like do like custom like painting on the faces
and makeup and stuff like that it's actually crazy uh so um
um so like honestly it is a huge work of art uh and i was
very honored that uh moon jewel a moonlight jewel wanted to
join the auction so uh very beautiful it's honestly um one
of these types of arts and crafts that i really admire and
uh i love watching doll customization in general uh so yeah
uh huge shout out to moonlight jewel uh all right next item
it's another plushie yeah having to paint the eyes is hard
and you also have to deal with like my joki joki joki amber
doge what are you doing you know i have chicken don't you
you know okay the best part is that i don't accidentally say
the wrong name this time
i think that was like the hardest thing for me
Hi, dad.
Do he have a doge?
You know I have chicken.
You're not allowed to have chicken.
You're allergic.
How many times I've told you.
You're fucking allergic.
He's like, I don't care if I'm allergic.
Okay.
All right.
Alright, my dad came in and was like, no, because I was
like, you, my other dad.
The human one came over and was like, here's some dog
treats.
Alright, next item, it is another plushie.
Where is it?
This one.
Oh my gosh, so tiny.
Another plushie.
Okay, we have one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine.
Nine more to go, guys!
We're almost there introducing this whole thing.
This has, this is a two hour intro, by the way.
Oh my god.
Welcome to the two hour intro to this whole event.
Very good time management.
Pleshy number two, three.
Sorry, I lost.
I can't even count anymore.
This one is by Febu Pleshy.
This is 20, seven years tall.
love how they have like the earrings too like the clip on
earrings because i don't actually by the way guys didn't
know this i i wear clip on earrings because i don't have my
ears pierced like
i actually this is actually finished as well so it'll be
like shipped to you guys um instantly um within two weeks
it'll be shipped to you guys um and i think the hat is
removable i believe so
so so i can be bald so you can remove the hat as well um
shit what was i gonna say fuck okay i forgot i wanted to say
something but i forgot okay anyway oh yeah about the earring
about the earring i actually do not have my ears pierced um
i'm scared of pain and that is why i refuse to have anything
done to my body
because i am a little bitch so i do not have my ears pierced
i um i wear clip this is a clip on earring uh no no tattoos
no piercings or anything uh it's just it's just it's just no
holes
worst part is that the i i i buy you know like b-show lovely
uh the the jewelry company not not sponsored by the way like
actually i really enjoy their product but they've done like
jewelry collaborations with uh with like medoka i talked
about my love for medoka many times i was like i'm still i'm
quite fucking obsessed with medoka And basically, they
released...
I basically brought their entire fucking merch jewelry line
for Madoka.
I mean, I could show...
Not sponsored.
I really enjoy their product.
So here's some free advertising.
But if you ever want to collab, well, you can message my
manager.
Yes, please.
sponsorships on your fucking charity stream.
Anyway.
Look, there's always time to shill a little bit.
This is, um, I do enjoy their products, okay?
I, I've been like buying their stuff for a while, okay?
All right.
Anyway, as I was saying, saying uh i know this is not this
is what i'm gonna show next is not queen street what i'm
gonna show next is not going to be on the auction i just
wanted to show you guys this to tell my story this is not in
the auction by the way so basically i bought they had like a
lot of other merchandise stuff but i bought this entire set
i can't wear it because like my My ears are not pierced.
I bought the entire...
I bought everything, basically.
Like, they had a lot of stuff.
They had, like, necklaces.
They had rings.
I also...
And then I...
They also...
Not in the auction!
This is just part of my tangents.
Just so you guys know.
This is not in the auction.
So, I bought, like, their entire line of Madoka.
even this even even this even though I don't have my ears
pierced I also bought this because it's just so beautiful
and like that is like the extent of my love for Madoka like
only the Madoka series I don't give a fuck about like the
spin-offs like the one I don't remember rebellion no not
rebellion the one where they're in another city and then
there's like rip off Madoka with a hood the the gotcha
madoka i don't know record not the same i'm sorry for people
who actually like the gotcha other like ripoff version of
madoka not the same and apologize to all the people that
spent thousands of dollars on that gotcha game only for them
to shut it down this is why you spend
not my medoka anyway um anyway but like i said yeah like
like i don't care about the spin-offs i just care about the
original all right next item next item where are we next
item oh this one's a fan favorite i believe i believe this
one is a a fan favorite it was so funny because we were um
someone said during the member stream when i was showing
like previews of the auction so people I've actually seen
some of these products already So now they're just getting a
two hour They like paid for no For no ads for like In the
member stream and now they're getting Like an unskippable
two hour ad Because they're like we were We've already heard
about This in the member stream and Now to hear this again
Okay Anyway Anyway As I was As I was saying, we have the
next product on here is The Tomato Dragoon plushie We got
the same as twice
Alright, do you have a tomato chonkoon Plushie?
And this is obviously completed She's 15.
Um, and look at this fucking monster of a tomato goon.
Look at it.
He's like, he's like a shiny.
But instead of a shiny variant, you're a tomato.
So like, the shiny variant of dragoons is basically their
shape like tomatoes.
And they're very rare because majority of the time when a
tomato goon is born, they usually don't live past um past uh
baby because like usually all the dragoons just eat it
because it's a tomato uh or i eat it because it's a tomato
so like if if a tomato goon lives past baby mode um baby
mode they are like they are very rare it's very very rare
because they're Like, they're so harvestable.
God, look how harvestable you are.
So, so it's very lucky that they are able to live past baby
mode and enjoy a very scary life of adulthood.
Anyway, but yeah, this is tomato.
They're like dodo's.
They're the dodo's of the goo.
basically they're the dodo's of the goons all right next up
oh this one I really like this one is this sculpture is so
fucking cute and I know like a lot of people are obsessed
with this outfit too the next item is another figure of me
in this fan favorite outfit uh this one is by littlest gifts
uh it is done so of course that means it can be shipped
within two weeks uh so if you win this auction you get it um
you are able to receive it quite fast uh so this one is
around 13 centimeters tall and it has like i love i the base
though the the base with the little stars and then
everything it's so fucking cute um but i know this is
obviously a fan favorite from everybody like everyone people
really love this outfit is also a really cute outfit i
honestly was one of my favorites as well so uh but yeah
another really cute sculpture that also will own um but it's
still one of a kind in public circulation for those who are
it's still it's still considered one of a kind Do not worry.
Alright, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
7!
Top 7 left!
Alright, plushie number 4!
Alright, where is...
Plushie number 4!
Alright, this is another outfit!
I feel like I have out...
I think all the plushies have, like, all my outfits in
general.
So, plushie number 4 by Luna Noctu Arts.
Um, well-known plushie artists within the VTuber community.
Uh, this is around 30 to 35 cm tall.
Uh, this one's not done yet, obviously.
Um, but, uh, another plushie to look forward to.
Uh, it's really, I think that's 30 to 35 cm.
So that's just pretty tall, actually.
But they have made a lot of plushies within the VTuber
community.
So you might recognize the work they have done.
And yeah, it's another, I believe the hat is removed.
Okay, actually I shouldn't say it.
I'll be like, if I say the hat is removable, and then the
plushie artist was like, it was not.
I was just like, but it was never removable.
What do you mean?
I don't know if the hat is removable.
Okay, I don't know if the hat is removable.
It could be.
But if it isn't, I won't force them.
make it removable so it's like trollinger's hat can it or
can it not be removable uh it is to be decided i just add
dlc like oh i have to redo the pattern now you gotta buy it
to find out exactly exactly if you really want to know i
guess you just have to buy
I mean, I guess if that's what it takes, you just have to
buy the hat to find out.
All right.
Sorry, I had to take a sip of my drink real fast.
Next up.
It is, I think we have two more plushies left and then also
other stuff.
This is the last two plushies and then we have other things.
It's not the last two items.
We have two more plushies left.
All right.
this is tiny me a tiny dokey plushy keychain by squeaky neko
uh yeah the post intermission is just me sipping on some tea
it's 3.5 inches tall it's very fucking tiny um but it is a
keychain and it's honestly incredibly cute um like look at
that it's the hat okay this one i can safely say that the
hat is definitely not removable
just so you guys know this hat is definitely not removable
so it's not false advertisement because i know for sure it's
not removable
so that's all i have to say okay doki amber dosh is mad
right now let me in let me in okay all right where was i
where was i all right the last plushie in the showcase
there's more guys there's more it's not the last item
there's more there is four more items left it is a little
dragon this is by uh sarasena uh this is 10 cent 10
centimeters tall i believe uh it comes with the back side
has like a little like bradding but it's so fucking cute
like i can show you like it's back uh but this is what it
looks like in the back so you can see the little butt tail
over there and yeah you get to own a little little tiny
dragon look at him you can fucking punt i was like jokey
don't say your intrusive thoughts i know you want to don't
don't say it anyway you can you can yeet it yeah Throw it
against the door!
Look at him!
You so...
Throw a ball!
It's like...
Okay, I almost said, like, some South Park thing.
You can...
Kick the Dragoon!
You know?
Just like in South Park!
You know, okay, back when, like, PlayStation...
One is like super popular back.
I mean all the playstations were super popular back in the
day But like um um um my you know like okay all you boomers
out there like okay this is like my dad's thing because he
was he's he is still a gamer like he's literally playing die
and light right now I think he's replaying die and I don't
know he's put I'm pretty sure he's replaying one of the die
and light games at the moment anyway on the ps5 it as i was
saying as i was saying um um you know like okay for those
zoomers out there who didn't who back in the day zoomers and
gen a gen alpha back in the day um we don't we had we don't
buy games digitally i know it's crazy
There was no steam back then I know Back then Valve used to
make video games It's actually fucking I know it's so crazy
You mean steam The creators of steam used to make video
games Video games Anyway Anyway So, my dad, so, like, back
then, like, PlayStation 1 games, people don't put the games
in the, in the boxes.
They put the, instead, instead, they buy these, like, giant
CD holder things.
They buy these giant CD holder, like, contain, not
containers, but, like, those flippy things.
The TF2 had updates insane.
I know.
1 his PlayStation 1 like game yeah CD wallets is that what
you call is that what you boomers call yes CD wallets so
that um I feel their dad is my age don't think that that
don't think that or I'll tell you how old place did you guys
know guys that the PlayStation okay when did the
came out in 1994.
Holy shit!
That's like...
Hell yeah.
Two thousand.
That's like 30 years ago.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I have to think.
That was 30 years ago.
Oh my, okay.
All right, anyway.
Anyway.
So my dad's CD wallet was actually the self-parked kick the
baby thing so like i was i when i would play around like the
thing is my entertainment um my entertainment when i was
like you know a fucking baby was like was like playing with
the cd wallet i mean like i wouldn't be playing on the
playstation because it was like the kick the baby and you
have to you squish the baby around in these like liquid like
things on the front and then i was like whoa oh my god this
is like so fun i wouldn't play the actual playstation one
game games in the day i would just play with the cd wallet
of kick the baby like it was it was like like a fucking like
core memory of mine of me just like squishing the baby
around.
Anyway.
Alright.
Next up.
Next item on the list.
Sorry for this random ad there.
For all you guys.
The next item.
It is.
A dokey themed necklace.
Alright.
This is a concept bar.
but it is also made of sterling silver um this is a joki
themed necklace that has obviously it's like in my colors
with the gems and everything as well as like the design as
well i remember i picked the con they gave me several
designs um and i feel like this was the one that best
represented um me and it is by elizabeth uh so really
beautiful necklace i really loved Like, I really love, like,
the design concept in general.
They're amazing, and jewelry designer, and it's really
pretty.
It's gorgeous, honestly.
Like, honestly, there's not a lot for me to say because it's
just a really beautiful piece.
And, like I said, it is one-of-a-kind in public circulation.
I hate that I can't say one-of-a-kind anymore because you
guys are so anal about that.
Not allowed to say one of a kind.
Anyway.
What is next?
Ooh, we are three more to go.
Three more to go.
Where is this one?
Where the fuck did I put the concept for this?
Okay, here we go.
I think it is.
This.
Alright.
This is a Doki-themed pyrography linking wood.
So for those who don't, this is by Wormwood Pyro.
So for those who don't know what pyrography is, it's
basically like flame torched art, which is crazy to think
about.
So if you look at their portfolio, I believe my mod, yeah,
my mod has linked their portfolio.
And you see, like, what they've done in the past and
everything.
So they're using fire to create art.
So, like, they draw it on the wood with fire.
And it's actually, their portfolio is insane.
It's actually very, very interesting to look at.
But very gorgeous artwork.
Indeed, obviously, this concept art.
But I'm pretty sure it's going to turn out amazing.
But, yes, it is, like, wood burning type deal.
Okay, last two guys.
We're in the final stretch.
Our two-hour ad is almost done.
Alright, two-hour ad is almost done.
Then we can go to the stretch goals for another ad break.
For a different type of ad.
Next up.
Two dokeybird signed prints.
Almost hot sauce time.
We're almost there at hot sauce.
okay all right this is two jokie bird prints uh and this
artist is this is by he so mean you so mean um is two signed
jokie bird prints beautiful artwork okay honestly gorgeous
artwork and they actually gave me two working progress like
i said this is just obviously it would there would be it's
going to be refined a bit more later but here is their other
uh this is their other print that would be sent to you guys
so this is the the two prints that'll be there yeah this is
the draft it's just a rough draft of the illustration um and
it will be signed by me i will not okay all right if this
print the auction for this goes to 2000 I feel like you guys
would be like, no, don't cover the belly It's gonna be like,
I will sign my name on the belly But then I feel like you
guys would like, no, you ruined it Okay, if it gets to 2k I
will let you choose where I sign I'll sign my signature
And um, so maybe you would want me to sign on the stomach Do
not ruin the stomach No You don't cover the belly!
No!
If it gets the 2K, I will let you pick where I'm side.
Or I don't know.
Well, it would be a shame if my hand gets there.
Alright.
Anyway.
Anyway, well, okay.
the last the last I that's kind of evil do hey hey hey it's
charity it's charity okay and oh yeah uh oh yeah okay last
item finally the last item is a custom wood keyboard it
comes with the key caps with the keycaps so it is a it has
um a dragoon printed on the keyboard itself um you'll see in
the backs as well there is a little dragoon in um in the
back oh he's doing okay he's he uh um uh he's he's okay he's
currently the top bidder and no one's sniping him yet so
he's fine I say yet because he still has like 22 hours
Someone in Asia might come over and be like I'm sorry
So So basically it is a full wooden keyboard With Dragoon
prints on it And it comes with a keycaps 34 minutes ago He's
doing fine for now now yeah he's doing okay guys nothing to
worry about he is doing a okay he just has to make sure
nobody on the other side of the world wakes up and was like
oh
that's all he has to worry about at the moment all right
holy fuck okay we took us a while But we finished
introducing every single item that is in the auction.
Like I said, a huge thank you to...
It's not hot sauce time.
We go by order.
We still...
We go by order of the goals, guys.
It's not hot sauce time.
We still have to do the...
We have to figure out the rest of the stretch goals.
And then we go by order.
Okay, time for the next ad.
for the next ad break.
Let's have a little intermission first.
Let me drink my fucking tea.
Okay.
As I was saying, as I was saying, I want to say, like I
said, a huge thank you and a huge shout out to all the
amazing creators that are part of this auction.
We couldn't have done it without everybody that applied.
Thank you to everyone that applied.
I'm really sorry if you didn't make it if you weren't able
to be a part of the final round that we chose for it.
Maybe in the future, because definitely, obviously I won't
do these types of auctions very frequently.
Like, you know, it's going to lose their spark and their
appeal for charity.
But maybe it will be something I'll do again maybe next
year.
Because it was a great pleasure to work with lots of amazing
creators to create these of a kind uh dokeybird items um so
uh good luck to everybody who wins it uh it is very
competitive as we've seen to like just from the first two
hours we have our items have reached like what 60 000 i'm
pretty sure more than 60k like if anybody has kept that
anyone kept count of like how how much was so oh nice 69k
we've like almost made 70 000 from just the uh from just the
auction alone so and it's just the first two hours too it's
just the first two hours of the auction so like i said it's
absolutely crazy that we've came this far all right time to
Add the stretch goal.
All right, all right.
All right, guys.
I will finally look at the stretch goal.
We gotta figure out the rest of the goals now.
We gotta figure out the rest of this.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
Okay, 50k and 60k.
Okay, let me bring up my list.
All right, guys.
This is a list we made during the members.
You can blame the member goons if you think it's a if you
think the list should be better
You can blame it on they they brainstormed this they
brainstormed this okay you can blame them If you think like
it could be better I'm trying to find what do you mean stop
stung I'm like deleting stuff to see the ones I've already
put Okay all right let's see let's see uh we've done that
already we put that in uh i've put that in all right okay
this is not a lot on the list i've realized because i just i
realized i realized i really inserted majority of the okay
we're gonna we're gonna come up with new things for the
stretch come up with more things on the stretch goals okay
guys because i already like here is what i have left okay
this is this is all i have left from the list we have after
deleting everything because all the other stuff is already
on all the other stuff is already on the fucking stretch my
fault it's not my fault all right i see a lot of mr mad look
i didn't ask him to but like i he's literally on my payroll
so like like i he's i literally pay him to do stuff so so
like i know i didn't ask for his permission
I didn't I didn't ask for his permission to be put used as
that but it's for charity though it's for charity so don't
you do not all I'm saying all it is for charity
look I'm as a great boss I am going to my manager to do an
ASM.
Okay, okay, I'll message it.
Hey, are you down to do an ASM?
I stream a channel for charity.
For charity.
Okay.
All right, look, see?
I asked him.
And it was very nicely asked, too.
I was like, hey, are you down to do an ASMR stream on my
channel for charity?
can't pretend that he's not here because I can literally see
that he's listening to something on Spotify.
I know whenever Mr. Man is online because he would listen to
us something on Spotify and I'll be like he's online, so he
can't pretend.
Oh, he said yes.
All right, that's gonna be him.
All right, I'm putting that in.
He said yes.
All right, I'm changing the 50k right now 50k is mr man ASMR
stream all right that's 50k and then 60k would be uh that is
I will get forklift certified I will get forklift certified
there you go all right there you go that is my 60k and then
we'll make one for we'll make one for 80k and then jumps to
100k because i'm gonna run out of stuff to give you guys so
what do you guys want for 80k you guys can come up with new
goals too because like i'm we've already fucking chose a lot
of stuff he has one different things we can also do that too
all right okay we already have the dokey bird asmr we
already have that
all right we already had the karaoke it's on we already
reached it guys we already reached it okay i know all right
i can't say like 24 hour streams because like i know my
fucking limits and that is a hard limit i i cannot survive
on 20 streaming 24 hours i actually like i cannot do i
remember trying to one time and it was like it was not good
it was not good at all okay all right at okay wait wait let
me think i'm trying to think 12 hour stream okay 12 hour
stream is like that all right i have an idea i have an idea
okay at 80k at 80k 80k but on was it april okay 80k wait we
already reached 80k never mind
sorry my parent mom came in is like we're gonna leave now
and i was like okay all right uh
guys i'm not gonna make my dad stream he doesn't know what's
going on
what okay all right all right if you guys want where are we
at total for auction okay what is the total for auction and
uh and and this guys what is the total what is the total
what is it's a 120k right now okay at 150k i will convince
my dad to stream on on his ps5 i'll convince him i'll
convince my dad to do a ps5 stream for you guys but it's
gonna be in chinese
No, not Doki Amberdoge, guys.
Okay, my dad will stream on his PS5 for you.
My human, okay, human dad.
I'll put that at 150,000.
Okay.
At 150,000, you will get that.
You don't want to get that.
We already have a 200k.
200k is Pokemon Smash or Pass.
Because he doesn't fucking play on PC.
He plays on the PS5.
He doesn't play PC games.
He plays on his PS5.
Guys, it's different.
A cover with Ditto?
Okay.
We already had 80k.
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
Do what cover do what cover with ditto I didn't ask her, but
she's totally down.
Okay
Because we we wanted to do it for a while We wanted to do it
for a while
She's totally down though.
She's totally down Totally down.
But like, it wasn't for charity.
She was...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, Mr. Man is asking you guys, how does the...
How does ASMR work?
Does...
Should he buy the ears?
Do you think he should buy the...
Just the one-off?
The one-off?
He gets the fucking ear...
The ear mics and stuff for the one-off.
The full set Mr. Man manages you For your streaming career
Manager RP Oh my god Okay guys I am not giving Mr. Man
$2,000 for this one stream There's no fucking way He's not
even a streamer I am not giving Mr. Man $2,000 for just one
stream like manager rp
okay all right oh shit wait uh my graphic designer finished
like a little graphics tab for the hashtag let me let me
download that real quick let me be more professional guys
for those who are like whoa what is your hashtag let me add
that on real quick more professional.
Let me add the hashtag graphic so you guys would know that
this is the hashtag.
Okay, there we go.
Whoa, wait, where is it?
Oh my gosh, it's fucking huge.
Okay, here you go.
Guys, if you guys were wondering, guys, this was the
hashtag.
For those who don't know, this is the hashtag.
For those who were confused, I wish I wanted to make sure it
wasn't covering anything.
Sorry for the name on the side that I'm covering.
For those who didn't know, this is the hashtag professional
streamer here.
Alright.
Where was I?
Okay.
Alright.
We have some of the stretch goals made.
Is that enough?
Is that good enough?
Alright, we got 60k forklift certified duet cover with
Ditto, who I know is totally fucking down.
Guys.
Guys, She is fucking down for this.
I know for sure.
Alright.
We are at 150k.
Because we're currently at 120k.
Right?
We are at 120k dollars raised.
I don't know what else to do.
What else do we do?
Is there any other stuff?
Can we change the 100k probably?
we already what do you you can't just be like there's no
backsees for this guys there's no like oh backsees can i
change that please all right at 250 because we're already at
120 right okay we're at 120 okay 120 okay okay 100 and wait
where are we at fuck okay uh we're at 120 120.
Okay, 2.
Do we have 250 yet?
250k.
I will...
Uh...
What's on my list?
Okay.
I will...
I will open commissions on stream for insert Pokemon here.
Poke.
Okay.
There you go.
It's just gonna be a poke.
I can't fit more.
Alright, there we go.
These are our shirt.
Okay.
Let's actually go through all the stretch goals you've
accomplished.
Let's all...
Let's all go through the stretch goals you've all
accomplished.
Chat picks Twitter profile picture for two weeks.
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna tweet it out.
The one...
has the most likes will be my twitter pro within twitter tos
by the way because i know people in the past who've done
this the people in the past who have done this actually got
locked by twitter because the twitter profile because they
got reported and people reported them and they got locked
out of their twitter account because it was against terms of
service i know elon musk owns Twitter now and he's very
relaxed about Twitter rules but apparently Twitter profile
pictures are very strict for some fucking reason compared to
the other stuff in the Twitter TOS so so so I will tweet it
out right now I'm gonna tweet it out the picture with the
most light um okay how
a picture for me to use as a profile picture for two weeks
the one with the most likes becomes my new profile picture
there we go i'm gonna tweet it out and within doki amber
doge what is it i know there's chicken i know you can't have
any no no No.
That's fucking right.
All right.
Okay, reply with a picture for me to use as a profile
picture for two weeks.
The one of the most likes becomes my...
The one of the most likes wins.
Okay.
There you go.
All right, here you're gonna tweet it out.
Good luck, guys.
I'm gonna...
Good luck.
Made a best picture wins.
Did people already have a picture?
How do you all have a picture?
Who the fuck put a tomato's ass?
How the fuck do you already have a picture?
All right.
Here's the tweet.
Go wild.
Go fucking wild with your ideas.
All right.
One stretch goal done.
next one and that's who my new papa is all right so my mama
will be a secret until uh until you know my skin suit is
done so but uh but I did get permission unlike the ditto
cover let me message ditto real quick
guys let me message ditto real quick about, like, if she
wants to do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry.
She is also asking about a collab.
Ooh, secret collab.
We'll be announced later.
It's for charity.
Guys, I'm not gonna fucking blackmail her with charity.
Not blackmail.
I'm not gonna manipulate her with charity, guys.
I'll just be like, hey, do you want to do a cover with me?
All right.
All right, there we go.
Anyway.
It's not blackmail.
It's manipulation, which I will not do.
Just so you guys know, it's actually manipulation.
But I will not be manipulating anyone.
was, will you do a cover with me?
I didn't mention charity!
I did not mention charity, okay?
Doki Ambertoge, what would you, what do you know?
What do you know?
Alright, here we go.
Okay, what else?
What else is on the stretch goals?
Alright, oh yeah, I was supposed to announce my pop-up.
Oh yeah, there's so many things to announce now that we've
reached numerous stretch goals okay my new papa let me like
grab their twitter real fast all right my new papa let me
like prop the
okay all right okay and then i'll follow them too so now
people be like whoa it's official it's official it's not a
secret anymore it's not not a secret anymore I've also
followed them so that's when you doki!
Amber Doge
please um um also Ditto consented so yeah cover approved now
it's official now it's official anyway where the fuck is the
okay all right so my new papa you might recognize their work
because um the reason why i picked them as uh as my papa was
because um they've done a lot of really amazing work and i
really love the fluidity of their skin suits um especially
like how well the mouth uh mouth works because mouths are
for this from I don't know if you guys know this but human
mouths are like really hard to get right so um that's why I
asked if they were able to to be my new papa and doing the
laundry and the the laundry of my new uh of my new skin suit
so this is Bye.
Papa!
Yay!
Okay, I'll post your Twitter.
Let's see if I can still.
All right.
For those who are wondering what they've done in the past,
they've done their most famous...
Or like not...
I don't know if it's like famous is the right word.
But their most well-known rigging is the one for...
Limeu or Limeu?
I think that Limeu, which is the green ferret, the green
white ferret.
So they've done, Celia has done a lot of amazing,
amazing models or skin suits in the past.
And like I said, their most well-known one was Limeu.
Limeu, I'm so sorry.
for mispronouncing I'm so sorry I'm please be patient please
be patient I'm a VTuber they've also they've also done
they've also done stuff for hollow stars as well so So
that's why I am very looking forward to working and with
working with them for the for my new skatesuit.
So yeah, my new papa!
When will it be done?
I don't know because it takes time.
Guys, I need you guys to remember this.
I was not really prepared for all of this.
So...
So, yeah, anyway.
is my new papa uh and that's why i am super excited i don't
know when yes it will be tomorrow it will not be tomorrow
guys i don't even know when it will be guys i just need you
guys to know i don't even know i don't even know please i
don't even know guys but that is gonna be my new papa
Anyway, all right, next sub goal, not sub goal, next stretch
goal, merch giveaway!
All right, so, like, I don't really know how to do it.
All right, I might need to ask Little Man's help if Little
Man is aware right now or, like, awake and watching.
If you're not awake and watching, Little Man, I will message
you.
I don't know who I'm telling this to if you're not watching,
but, like, Like, I need to figure out how to do the merch
giveaway on stream.
But I'm...
Little Man's watching!
Okay, Little Man, can you help me figure out how to do a
merch giveaway?
Do we do it on Twitter?
We could do it on Twitter.
Okay, wait.
I...
We can do the classic!
Like him or just comment.
Honestly, you don't have to like him retweet.
Just comment.
All right.
Actually, you should retweet because apparently when doing
Twitter giveaways, It's so fucking hard to...
It's actually so difficult to, like, to, like, to, like,
grab random...
Like, usually they look at retweets, like, those, like, bots
that does, like, Twitter giveaway pickers, like, where they
pick the people.
Please.
I will kick you out of my room.
But then, oh, man.
Help me figure out what's the best way.
Retweet or...
comment or like on twitter or do it on stream anyway i will
be giving out um five five bundles from the debut and five
bundles from the lunar new year bundles so um so like it's a
lot because like um i feel like since there's a lot of you
supporting okay i know 10 is might not be a lot to give away
but it's the bundle
so um it would be a 10 merch that will be giving away but
also we're figuring out how to enter uh well we're gonna
we're gonna figure out how to enter this don't worry little
man and mr man figuring this out for me okay i'm gonna kick
you out you pinani okay guys give me a sec we got i got him
he can't the thing is he can open doors now like okay he
like Okay, because my door fucking sucks.
All he does is that he, like, pushes the door with his paw
or his nose.
And he's like, I'm here now.
Okay.
All right.
I'm not picking up the fucking chicken.
Here you go.
He's even...
No!
Nope!
Nope.
All right.
Go.
Here you go.
All right.
All right, he's out.
He did nothing.
What do you mean?
I'm trying to have a conversation.
He did nothing wrong.
All right.
All right, anyway.
All right, he's out of the room now.
He's out of justice for dad.
Justice for dad.
Bro, the moment I, like, picked him up, he, like, tried to,
like, go for the chicken.
He's like, oh, my God, I'm taller now.
Oh, my God, I'm now in reach of the chicken.
I'm like, nope, nope, other way.
Other way out the door.
All right, anyway, as I was saying, he was like, oh, look at
the chicken.
all right what is I saying what was I saying but okay all
right let's pick out the next merch drop I'll give you guys
you guys give me four suggestions on the theme of the merch
drop and I'll let you pick one product to be made in
production in this drop so that is the choices I'm giving
you guys most likely it has to be within um So, like, the
theme has to fit.
Obviously, I can't get it made in production really fast.
So, like, just plus four months.
And then, one, two, three, four.
So, July and after.
Guys, I can't do Easter.
I cannot do, like, I cannot do Easter.
Because it's way too soon.
The merch shop will come up in, like, after, like, with
July.
and after maybe after july so okay there's summertime i see
some swimsuit okay i'll say summertime okay summertime uh uh
we're not gonna be able to do this in saint patrick's we're
definitely not able to do this with saint patrick's all
right okay tomato themed Don't fucking tomato All right
Summer Tomato Okay Halloween is so generic Like you gotta
assume that I was gonna make a Halloween theme Anyway Try to
think like Try to expand your horizons chat We need you to
expand your horizons right now Think beyond Like the generic
themes Okay Halloween Uh Oh, not Halloween.
Fuck.
Okay, now you're fucking with me.
Tomato!
Summer festival or summertime.
Tomato.
Summer.
Um, what else?
What else, guys?
We're not gonna make America.
Okay, I will put America as I swear to God.
Like, July 4th is literally my birthday.
You guys ready?
It's literally my birthday.
All right.
Okay.
We'll do America.
No.
America's birthday was named after my birthday.
Okay.
They're celebrating my birthday.
Last one.
Tomato.
Summer.
America.
All right.
What's the last theme you want?
all right and then we're gonna put it up to a vote it'll be
up to a vote for all of you we're not apex we're not i'm not
gonna get fucking caught despite ea having a group
relationship with me i do not want ea to i don't want to
piss them
okay magical girl okay that those are the four those are the
four right all right we're gonna
we can decide what specific i and we vote for the item that
you really really want in the drop all right um theme for
merch drop okay tomato america
yeah there could have been like cooking or like masquerade
or like you know like you know like There could have been,
like, very nice themes, but instead we got America Tomato.
Okay, magical girl.
I don't even know what...
I guess we could do jewelry for magical girls.
All right, here we go.
The theme for the merch drop.
All right, I will give you guys...
I'll give you guys, like, 10 minutes to figure out why we
do...
The, while we talk about, I can't, okay, we're gonna have to
do a poll for the chat picks, do I cover what you, you son?
By the way, I did get permission.
Just so you guys know, we do have permission to do a cover,
you son.
In case people, in case people are like, did you ask you
son?
Thankfully, you son was totally down.
Thank God.
um um anyway anyway as i was uh as i was saying uh as i was
saying what was i gonna say fuck okay i already lost my
count all right uh yes summer can be like beach and uh this
is not bathtub it's a beach sorry i just had to say that out
loud it was like fucking plaguing my mind anyway anyway as i
was saying um i can't do the vote for the usan cover yet
because obviously uh we need to use the poll the poll is
being used right now for you know for for the theme for the
merch shop um anyway we are going holy shit the metal poster
is on five K?
Oh my god!
You really like paper.
You really?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm like, oh really?
I'm like, wow.
Holy shit.
You know what?
Good for that guy.
It's, sorry.
Sorry.
Metal paper.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot.
oh my god i mean i'm not surprised that metal paper has like
more people bidding on it than regular paper i'm not
surprised about that holy fuck okay anyway as i was sorry i
got like really distracted by the paper there looking at it
um as i was saying leaking upcoming projects and work in
progresses so this is something i asked mr man like there's
like stuff i asked like stuff i wanted to like show you guys
like uh and stuff that like mr man said i can reveal uh um
reveal like everything about it but I can say like I can
reveal like parts of it so yes this is Mr. Man approved like
we had to ask permission if I can reveal it on stream um and
they said yes but only like parts of it um but basically
drum roll please so it's like America is losing alright the
first thing I'm gonna leak or announce is okay I need to
make sure I don't like accidentally say the wrong thing I
never read what I can say okay the first thing is that I
will be at Anime Expo I can't reveal in what way but I will
be at Anime Expo
Future Details will be announced at a later time But this is
what I can say for now This is what I can This is This is
but yeah that's that's what a big it's like soon details
regarding sorry mr man was like you can say this and i was
like okay it will be announced very soon apparently
apparently very soon it will be announced the details of
like how i will be at anime expo um uh but i will be there
uh that's i can say for now uh so yeah um for those who were
thinking about whether or not to go to anime expo um if you
guys want to potentially meet me uh this could be your
chance uh but yeah anyway that is the thing i can say for
now anyway something else i can i can or like not announce
sorry uh leak is that i am getting a new intro made and i
guess since we reached our goal i can show you guys the new
intro i think um i think a lot of people are gonna be pretty
happy with this intro.
It's still a work in progress but I can show you guys the
video of it since you guys made it to you know, since you
guys got it all the way to the end, got reached the goal.
I can show you guys the intro.
Alright, let me see.
I can pull it up.
Alright, where is it?
Okay, let me see.
Let me find it.
okay let me like actually okay give me a sec guys i wasn't
ready to like show it to be honest i wasn't ready to show it
so guys give me a little scuffed i need to like find what i
can replace right now so give me a sec i need to find it
because it's somewhere
All right.
I think the volume is going to be very...
I'm so sorry.
The volume is like incredibly loud.
All right.
Okay, guys.
If the volume is incredibly loud, I am so sorry.
I don't know where this is going to show up.
All right.
Let me make sure I chose the right one.
Plushies, thank you for 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you again for joining me.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay, I think this is it.
Alright, I'm so sorry if this is really loud.
I'm really, really sorry.
I'm going to mute the song real fast.
Yeah!
That's right!
If you guys didn't know, that song is actually Public
Domain.
Oh my god!
Bacon, thank you for that, Finn.
D-gifted chips.
Thank you.
Oh.
Um, but yes.
That is being worked on at the moment.
I believe it will be done around maybe mid-March or end of
March.
It really depends on the animator.
Um, I love working with this animator.
Um, I've been working with them since for like three, four
years, I think.
I've always loved their work.
to be able to keep working with them and to make a new intro
honestly my favorite part is like the dancing the dancing
dragon I love I love I just love to see the little dragon
just like hopping around he's like it's so cute that's
honestly my fucking my favorite part in the whole thing it's
with the little stick legs yeah it's so fucking cute um but
yes uh huge shout out to hoopion um i've always loved
working with them and i was so happy that they would like to
still work with me um on this new intro and oh my gosh it's
just so cute i oh it's honestly really fucking adorable
oh my god i just oh my gosh the little hops the little hops
is just so good Richard thank you for the 10 gift that's
just thank you thank you um but yes look forward to that at
the end of march where it will be uh where it will be
released where i will finally be able to use it um i know um
in the future it's definitely gonna get updated whenever i
do getting new has like blocked off a day a month a general
month to like rework on it later on in the future to update
it to update it if needed so it might not be the one version
of the intro there's going to be more versions of this intro
in the future so something else to look forward to so it
might not be like I whenever I do get the updated skin suit
it the intro is going to look different um but for now it's
based off my current skin suit yeah like i'll still be using
oh it will be basing it off of my current skin suit for now
and then she she's gonna edit it to update it in the future
so yes that is i don't know let me see if there's anything
else i can legally show you
Let me double check if there's anything else that I can, um,
I mean, I've talked about this before, but the next big
event slash project that I'll be working on after, I think I
talked about in general, but like I never said it
officially, but the next official project that I'll be
working on, um, that I've been in talks with Mr. Man.
about this um is going to be like this the next event i'm
planning on because this is like more so of a small scale
you know like the the hardest part of doing all this was the
auction in general but the next event that i'll be hosting
um after this will be the uh vtuber w w uh sorry not w no
That will be my next official event that I will be
organizing after the charity.
So it's all still being planned and everything.
Like it's being like brainstormed at the moment on the
logistics of everything that's going to be going on.
But the next big event I'm planning on will be VTuber slash
wrestling event.
is mine so it's sort of like for those who are like
wondering what it's gonna be like so it's sort of like
wwe-esque so like it's like wrestlemania type deal uh uh so
it's gonna be like similar to that but for vtubers uh and
that is what i'm working on after this obviously i was
wanting to like work on multiple things at the same time but
mr man little man was like one at a time dokey
One at a time, but like, it's like, but I want to do
everything.
No, no, no.
Focus on your charity event, Doki.
So, that is the next event I'm planning on.
But what if I want to do everything?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
You got to put all your energy on this for now.
I'm like, okay, I guess I will.
um oh yes okay also uh let me ask little mad they can make
me a template can you make me a tweet template it's so nice
having assistance i give you for the give it's so nice i'm
like can you write my tweet for me for the giveaway while i
talk to my chat
okay also wait let me see if i can announce this give me a
sec i'm gonna i'm gonna look at what they i'm gonna look at
like okay uh oh okay yes all right um by no way okay this is
not really like a big announcement or anything but like apex
legends gave me like free codes to give away um to give away
to people but it's like it's like i think like i think it's
like um it's like apex coins and like the new like skins or
stuff for um for the new event that's gonna for the new
beast collection giveaway event giveaway event and i'm
allowed to give them away on the fourth so like i'm just
gonna be like if you if you want to enter uh
I'll tweet that out on the 4th, but I'll just be like, if
you want to enter.
What do I make you guys say?
Because last time I was like, meow for me.
I was like, meow for me, kidden.
The last time I did this.
No, the last time I did this, I say meow for me.
I need to do something else for you guys to make you guys do
something else embarrassing.
all right okay how do i embarrass the dragoons for free apex
coins how do i what do i park for no no if you had a persona
what will it be we have no shame all right um okay i'll do
like reply with uh
all right i don't know i don't know yet i'm trying to figure
out what to i'm trying to figure out like what to make you
guys reply with um for a chance to win a for a chance to get
win the giveaway code so i'll figure that out later i'll
figure that out later for you guys um all right all right
else is there an image of said merch oh yeah i do okay let
me give oh it's it's in the server i'll just write that i'm
too lazy right now to give it to them individually it's in
the server i don't need a i don't need a link it's in the
server um oo for codes oh yeah i did that that's good that's
actually pretty good that's actually pretty good oo for
codes all right next up okay oh the tomato one i'm actually
surprised i thought magical okay the next it won't be it
might not be the next one but like it would be like we will
have this so oh yeah the background music was muted whoops i
didn't even realize thanks for letting me know all right so
the next theme i need to write this down for myself uh uh
okay uh let me write this okay tomato merch drop info okay i
just wrote that in the server just to remind myself all
right tomato themed merch drop what is the one thing.
I would do one thing that you request.
What is the one thing that you guys want in the tomato merch
drop?
What is the one thing?
A plushie.
Tomato.
Okay, I'll give you guys three things to vote for instead
for.
Tomato plushie.
What else?
And then you guys pick for the tomato.
They can't all have dockies.
I'm not gonna make dockie macuras for everything.
I'll put it there.
Tomato docky.
Tomato plushy.
Look, only one thing can win, guys.
Only one can win.
I need you guys to know this.
I almost wrote tomato bundle for the giveaway.
I said that the letter.
okay all right all right let's see i'm not giving you guys a
fresh okay all right i okay okay the tomato mouse pad all
right so you know it's like buba but like instead it's
tomato so we're in okay only one can win in this poll though
all right okay the what the requested item in the Tomato
themed merch drop.
Only one can win.
There will be other items in there, but it won't be the
others.
Alright?
Okay, tomato plushie.
Tomato dockie.
Tomato.
Oh my god.
It's like, okay.
There's like this famous Animal Crossing boobab mouse pad,
but instead of tomato, it's like the Animal Crossing fruits,
and that's like what I'm thinking of right now.
That's actually what I'm thinking of.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
The requested item in the tomato theme.
Alright, let me see.
I'm gonna see if I can pull it up.
Animal Crossing.
Oh my god, this is so... It's gonna be so cursed.
This is gonna be so bad if it doesn't show up the one that I
expected.
Oh yeah.
It's so bad.
Oh, it's this one.
I think I actually, I think I almost bought this one.
I'm pretty sure I almost bought it because I was like, oh my
god, this is so cute.
But it's this.
Let me show you guys.
It's this.
So it'll be like this, but tomatoes instead.
Like, it's like, it's so cute though.
It's so cute.
I actually, I almost ordered.
this because I was so... The thing is, I would never use it.
I would never use it because I have a gamer mouse pad.
But like, it's so cute.
But instead of the fruits, it's the tomatoes.
But only if it wins, of course.
It's only if it wins, guys.
If you're like, guys, please, we could have tomatoes!
Please!
It's hard to vote for it because there's so many choices.
There's so many choices, but only one can win chat only only
one can win and then the rest would be like only there can
only be one super high production item because like i can't
afford to make several super high production
guys so only only one can win guys i'll give you guys five
minutes to vote for your themed item and then and then we'll
move on from there okay what else what else can i show you
guys what else oh you guys want to see the next doki bites
short that well that's still being worked on um i can show
you guys that that one's really cute to show it's actually
so funny i'll leak that one too i'll leak to you guys the
the next doki bites animated animated short all right i'm
pretty sure this might be the one that's released next
judging by like how um judging by like the timeline of
everything i'm pretty sure this one is the next dokey bite
short that's being released let me that would be the last
thing i'll leak out for you guys uh regarding everything
that would be the last thing and we're gonna move on to the
next stretch goal all right let's see is this the right one
yeah You might recognize this animator.
I'm really happy to keep working with them, honestly.
All right, let me turn off my mic.
Butter my biscuits.
What a tarnation do you want, you colorful critter.
I'm a woman.
My apologies, man.
What can I do for you?
Okay.
Okay, all right.
Wow, that's a very big gun.
I wish I could have a closer look.
now hold on there partner this here gun ain't no toy for
gestures like yourself best keep your distance and you know
what's good for you so why don't you tell me what you really
came here for wow okay wait wow sir oh dangerous huh i love
danger Actually negative risk Yeah!
Alright, that was the You might recognize that I worked with
this animator Multiple times, so I'm very happy To be able
to keep working with him I think my favorite part was like
It's just like the The x-ray vision on the tomato That's
like my favorite part I It's like the inner dokey.
Oh my god, you recognize the voice.
I know, I know.
It's so talented voice acting, guys.
I'm so happy you guys were able to recognize the voice
actor.
Both voice actors are incredibly talented.
I can't believe we were able to...
I can't believe we were able to get them for the short.
Is that crazy?
I can't believe we're able to get them
It was very hard to hire Hire They they're really booked up
on their work schedule So I'm just oh my god I'm just so
happy it was possible guys I'm so happy She was a bit at Oh
my What do you say?
Excuse me
all right okay let me see what else let me see what else is
on the stretch goal all right give me a sec okay all right
we got the we got the leak upcoming projects and work in
progress all right we'll do a karaoke stream in march that i
don't have to plan or anything it's a march stream that have
the plan all right bento stream chat desires theme and
design okay that will need to be voted on god there's so
many voted okay there's so many voted on stretch goals i did
not think this through there's not i did not think this
through all right the winner is the tomato plushie all right
so we will have the tomato plushie as i think the bento
thing i'm gonna make a hashtag for it as well as we will
i'll make a community post for the bento stuff so um so it
lets me have time to think about it instead of like doing
deciding it right off the bat because like ben building
bentos and stuff actually takes time for me to like
brainstorm everything and craft materials so the bento
stream uh the bento like ideas and all that stuff that will
be decided in a community post later.
Alright guys, instead of voting for stuff, I will do the hot
sauce.
Guys, I...
I will do the hot sauce.
Let me write down for myself.
I need to write down for myself tomato.
I'm gonna put tomato plushie.
Let me...
Tomato plushie.
I need to write this down for myself.
All right.
I'll show you guys the hot sauce.
Okay.
I'm just going to grab it off Google this easier because,
like, it's the last dab experience.
Okay.
All right.
This is 2 million, by the way.
I need you guys to know that this hot sauce is 2 million.
The basketball hat is finally finished.
This is only the intermission.
What do you mean?
We're back and at very soon after this.
This is just the intermission.
Okay.
Anyway.
All right.
So this is, this is the over 91% pepper, by the way.
Um, yay.
This is the hot sauce that I will be using.
It is 2 million.
Alright, I feel like let me, I need to play a song that
matches this.
Let me YouTube a song real quick.
I swear, if they claim this song, it's fine.
It's not even.
Like, this is a cherry stream.
What if they claim it?
I just realized, wait, this is a charity stream.
I don't give a fuck if they claim this.
I almost forgot.
I was doing this for charity.
I was thinking about content.
I was thinking about...
Okay.
Is it...
Alright.
It doesn't matter what song I play anyway.
As long as it's not blocked.
Is this song good?
Can the church copyright claim me?
I don't...
I swear.
The church copyright...
Copyright claim me.
I swear to God.
I swear to God at the church.
Copyright claim me.
Alright.
I'm gonna shake this.
Grabbing the chicken.
Okay, six minutes.
I have six minutes to...
Okay.
Jesus is not public.
of me
Jesus please don't kill me my video it's charity
I'm so scared I'm gonna
oh it has to be louder so I can like feel God I need to be
louder I need God by my side oh my god you wash my hands
after this too i'm so scared
okay oh okay pouring the hot sauce on my chicken
okay boy i'm just making sure i don't pour too much
oh my god what the fuck oh that's too much oh
my god it's so oh my god i can smell how spicy this is oh no
oh i can smell the spice oh i was not scared with the other
hot sauce other hot sauce are we're fucking weak but like
two million two million is way too much million oh my god 2
million is just too too many millions the other ones were so
weak but 2 million it's 90 it's 98% pepper yes this hot
sauce is 2 million shu okay
okay please
Stop!
I need to feel Jesus!
Guys!
I'm not feeling the Jesus yet!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
3.
2.
I can smell the pepper!
It's like...
It's like 30 centimeters away from you.
I still smell the pepper.
Okay, maybe.
30, 20, 27 years away from me, and I still smell it.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh my god.
I don't eat more chicken.
Milk is for pussies.
Oh, yeah.
okay oh my god oh my god oh fuck okay oh fuck okay i'm gonna
sit with the spice for a little bit oh
my god okay
Okay.
Oh my god.
Fuck, okay.
I'm a pussy.
Oh my god.
I should laugh.
I should...
Okay, fuck.
Oh!
Oh, oh, okay.
It actually tasted nice, though.
Other than it being extremely spicy, oh my god, it's still
burning.
It's still burning.
Oh, I was saying.
It's very spicy It's like I still feel the spice On my
tongue I still feel it But there's flavor Fuck okay Oh It's
better than the bomb It's actually It's It, like, it has
flavor.
Like, that's all I asked for.
Oh.
But it's, oh my gosh.
It's like, it's like, it's spilling.
I tolerate, it's, it's very spicy.
Oh my gosh.
It's very, oh my gosh.
I can feel it in my cheeks.
What the fuck?
What's wrong with this pepper sauce?
Okay.
It's very spicy.
but it actually has a nice taste will I do it again honestly
honestly if I have I don't have enough milk I literally only
have like two I like my milk is like barely done I only have
like one more sip of milk left
oh but oh my Oh my god, it's like pinching my cheeks.
I like feel like the pinch on my cheeks.
Oh my god.
It's like...
I don't know.
Okay, it's like those spice that builds up.
It builds up.
And it's like pinching.
It's like pinching.
I feel like if you don't have the spice tolerance like me,
you're so fucked.
Yeah.
Like I wouldn't say like, oh my god, I'm gonna fucking die.
That's so fucking spicy.
I wouldn't say that I would say that I think it's very spicy
But it's not like I'm gonna fucking die So if you don't have
my spice tolerance You're so fucked like because even I was
like damn that like I could feel like the pinching on my
cheeks um it's definitely not going to be doing very well in
my stomach like at least i'm not like mixing all of it like
last time that one was bad that was very bad but i would
definitely say um i grew up with spicy things so i live but
like if you don't grow up with spice i i don't know what to
say i think you'd be pretty fucked anyway i'm gonna eat my
chicken we'll know i'm gonna eat
I deserve this.
I deserve my chicken.
Alright.
Now, of course.
It's a non-sauce chicken.
I deserve more chicken.
But, like, not the spicy one.
Oh, my God.
My eyes are watering, though.
Holy shit.
I feel like it's not as fun when I have, like, the Asian
face tolerance, though.
I have the Asian spice tolerance So like Oh shit Give me a
sec guys I need to wash my hands I need to make sure Don't
touch my eyes Give me a sec
Alright I'm back Alright Alright like I said Fuck the bomb
ha sauce That shit tasted like metal Like I don't understand
They can make perfectly reasonable sauce, hot sauce, that
actually tastes like something, like, tastes like something
good.
But then they made the bomb, which is just metal.
It just actually tastes metal.
Like, the bomb was so fucking bad.
Holy shit.
But this one's, like, actually, it's, if it wasn't so
fucking hot, I would try it again.
I would try, what is it called?
I would try the last stab experience if it didn't if it
wasn't like i mean okay to be fair if i had another if i had
more milk if i had more milk i will actually do another bite
i'll do another chicken for it but like i barely have enough
milk for this so it's not worth it it's not it's not worth
it
so like i wouldn't i wouldn't fucking i wouldn't i would not
like push that boundary all right what's the next stretch
goal what is it um like i i haven't played a single game
i've just been i hope you guys have been entertained despite
the many non-skippable ads i i hope you guys have been
Okay, okay, let's see, what's the next one that is, okay,
um, do I cover with you son?
So, um, you son is totally down to do it.
Um, they were actually at first down to do it without the
charity, and then I was like, no, let's do it for charity,
because like, you know, it's a, it's a good cause.
Um, let me read, um, okay, so basically, um, the duet cover
with yusun you guys get to decide what song um we can do
together um and uh yusun will be in charge with uh getting
the mixers and the instrumentals and then i will be in
charge of finding the artist and the mv editor i will be
funding i will be funding the entire video uh but uh but
we're like splitting the job so like i would still be paying
for instrumentals and mixers um but um but like islam will
be in charge of finding them because like you know they are
a singer and they're much more experienced with that type of
thing um so we will decide on um where you guys get to pick
uh what duet cover we will do together um i will say if you
know um i guys okay this is very off topic but one of my
favorite
This is super off topic, but I don't know if you guys know
this, but one of my favorite songs is, Deaf Should Not Have
Taken The...
Fun...
It's just so off topic, guys.
It's so off topic, but I like to say...
that um death should not have taken thee is honestly one of
my favorite um uh duet songs out there but obviously this
has nothing to do with like the cover with with yusam but i
love you know wonderful opportunity is like one of my
favorite like jp uh uh Vocaloid artists and oh my god
hearing like uh all I'm saying is that oh my god like you
guys should totally like listen to this song
and like oh it's just such a good song though right
Got someone be like, that would be great for a second cover,
you know?
That would be great.
So I was like, oh yeah, like for your second cover, right?
Like, wow, yeah.
I just, I'm just saying, I'm just saying.
It's so off topic, anyway.
Anyway, as I, anyway, it's super off topic, though.
But like, what, what, what are your, what are your, What
song do you guys want what you son and I to what song do you
guys want you son and I to do?
Uh,
yes, yeah.
What suggestions do you guys have?
Okay, we cannot do free bird because they already
demonetized me the first time.
So I refuse to do free bird.
bird has generated enough revenue off of my first stream
back like they have i will veto free bird just because
they've already generated enough income from that stream
so i i will veto free bird because of it um i heard rokey
rokey's a nice song i think rokey's a great song too for uh
uh for a cover um all right rokey what are what other
suggestions do you guys have we will have a poll with four
choices just like last time and then you guys can vote uh
for the one you guys want to hear the most um oh my god why
are you guys suggesting like the fucking hardest song is
that I would never be able to sing.
Like, guys, you saw what sound amazing.
But you guys have to remember, I am also singing it.
Like, I am also singing it.
Like, the, what was it?
Usay?
Is that the, is that how you pronounce it?
Like, that, there is no fucking way I'll be able to sing
that.
Holy fuck You thought it would sound amazing
Alright Okay let's see Oh bro Thunderware I like Death
should not have taken the That is such a good suggestion
Thunder Wow you for suggesting that.
That is a really good suggestion for a song cover.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
I was reading off chat.
Guys!
It's not rigged.
I was literally reading off chat.
Guys.
I don't know where... I was... I was reading off chat.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I literally... Someone literally wanted me to sing that.
Oh my Thank you, Ma.
I just started linking that song.
That is a good suggestion.
I would gladly put that on the poll.
Paid out there.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I was just reading off of the chat, guys.
What do you mean?
read off of chat.
Alright.
It's oh wow.
What is this?
Bro, there's no way I can sing that song.
There's no way I can sing the last step.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's these songs that like I can actually be able to sing
guys i mean we could also do like um all right guys please
within my vocal range chat i know you guys think i am very
talented but like there's some things that i know i know i
i'm i really hate to break it to you but like i'm not
perfect i know i i'm sorry i'm so sorry i i I know it's
great.
I didn't even want to say this.
But I'm not perfect.
I'm not perfect.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
There have limitations.
I have limitations when it comes to singing.
I'm so sorry I didn't want to tell you this But I had to
before it's too late I'm sick No the immersion You were
supposed to be perfect Doki How could this happen
Ponyo!
Okay, I like that
oh my god i can sing like the english cover too i don't know
if you someone wanted to do that i love that song so much
though holy shit all right okay nice drop pot candy wait
drop pop candy is pretty nice too fuck okay drop pop candy
Okay, I'm sorry, but, like, my favorite version of Drop Pop
Candy has to...
Okay, but, like, have you guys heard the Undertale version
of Drop Pop Candy?
All I'm saying is that, not gonna lie, the Undertale version
of Drop Pop Candy is pretty fire.
fucking fire oh I mean come on it's pretty good like it's
it's pretty good wait okay but what if we do the oh wait but
I don't know if you son can sing in Chinese I don't know I
don't know song can sing in chinese maybe not because i was
like oh hey i need this that's a duet too that's a that's a
no i don't think you suck at singing chinese there's no i
feel like i don't know
uh let's see i'm trying to think okay okay all right how
about dream dream pop candy Wait, was it Dream Pop Candy?
I don't really...
I don't remember.
Was it Dream Pop Candy?
Uh...
That should not have taken thee.
Which, by the way, I think...
If you, Son, and I did that...
Son, it would be...
It would sound so good.
Okay.
all I'm saying
okay okay all right anyway do it cover what if you saw that
should not have taken the uh this was like please stop uh
was it drop pop I don't even remember from his drop cup.
Yeah, I said dream pop candy.
Okay, drop pop candy.
Rookie.
You know what?
We'll do these three.
Ponyo can be... I feel like Ponyo wouldn't really fit, to be
fair.
Uh, alright, here we go.
Choose.
It is time.
It is time to pick.
Oh my god.
hold guys oh my god I can't believe it guys I can't believe
that should not have taken thee is winning the vote
don't let her ring guys Holy shit I'm so surprised Guys, oh
my god This is actually insane Who would have thought Can we
Go on straight You know guys Guys I will give you I will
give the poll to be up for You know, maybe like Two more
minutes I mean one more Minute So All right, fellas, I've
got a sip.
Thank you, Keith.
That's why you're my favorite.
All right, guys.
Oh, my God.
It seems we're almost a minute up, guys.
Whoa.
All right.
Don't worry, everybody.
I will do a little countdown.
I'll do it.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm going to do a little countdown.
So we all know that this is all fair.
It's the fair vote, guys.
Just so you guys know.
Damn.
Oh, I can't believe we're doing...
I can't believe we're doing the song.
How did you guys know this was one of my favorite chat?
How did you know this is one of my favorite songs?
Oh my that's like crazy.
I'll do a countdown everybody so you can get your last
minute votes in.
Ten.
Nine.
Eight.
Seven.
Six.
Five, four, three, two, look, look, look, look, I'll even
give you guys more time.
Two and a half, two and three quarters, two and five
quarters.
I don't think that's how math works.
One, whoa, zero.
Oh my god.
Def should not have taken thee?
Well, if you guys say so, I guess...
I guess we're gonna do this song!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't.
I can't believe.
Deaf should not take any one.
Truly is the magic of voting.
Man, I love voting.
oh my god guys isn't it great feels just like hell divers
too
oh my god my love managed democracy
okay all right all right nice all right nice okay we got
that stretch goal out of the way to america don't you don't
you love it here all right i'm gonna see the poll i'm gonna
see the i swear to fucking god is this actually i okay
apparently the the art of tomato bikini is winning the poll
is winning the uh yep it is yep it's the most it's the most
liked at the moment that has the most likes.
People are going to be so fucking confused.
I'm going to be so fucking confused.
Alright, the next, the next one.
Uh.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god, I've been streaming for like almost four hours.
That's like, I feel like that.
No, five hours has been the longest I've ever stream because
of batman okay okay let's see we have the next thing that is
up is what is it chat decides the next outfit oh sorry
outfit themed four hour long at i am trying my best here
God.
Okay.
Anyway.
It could have been a five hour long ad.
Okay.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
The next chat gets to pick.
The next outfit themed.
um new exist okay guys guys guys okay uh i will give you
guys four choices to pick i see alternative themed uh that
one's an official outfit already like it's not really i
guess like i guess if you want to see me with that skin suit
on um okay one is the alternative girl doki the The other
one is, okay, I'm trying to see if there's another one.
Tomboy.
Okay, tomboy themed.
Alright, what's the third?
There's two more choices for you guys.
Magical Girl.
Okay, Magical Girl.
What's the fourth?
I'm trying to see which one has the...
Which one...
I'm trying to see which one is gonna...
Um...
Which one?
The fourth, guys.
the fourth or there's gonna be only three
all right i only have three guys a lot of you guys are like
different steampunk steampunk would be interesting actually
that'll be an interesting one all right okay i'm gonna put
the pull up now another pull next outfit themed next outfit
theme Okay, alt girl, uh, what was the magical girl, tomboy,
and then the next one, what was the last one?
Okay, was it steampunk?
Steampunk.
Okay, here you go.
All right, we'll put that for 10 minutes.
this one has the privilege of having 10 minutes
this is wrong it's just like the just like the last poll you
know the last poll had 10 minutes as well guys I don't
the last poll also had the equal amount of time as the
current poll so oh my god tomboy is like so fucking it's so
it's so ahead I honestly am surprised I'm surprised because
like I thought you guys would want the uh the other one but
magical girl had like they're the loudest the old girl is
like the loudest speakers in chat but like the quiet the the
quiet majority are for tom boys i just found it funny the
quiet majority right there uh all right let me look at the
next stretch clothes the next one let's see
like the the voice pack theme i will do that um on the
community post for everybody to decide because like that is
like a lot it's a lot to talk about so the voice pack and
the bento one will be done um will be done uh a separate in
the community post and uh we'll do that another time for
that uh what else what else do we have let's see does anyone
know how much we made we made in total from the auction can
anyone let me know honey know what goals we've hit i know
what goals we're at right now guys i need my i need my human
calculators this is it this is your time to shine 71 000
holy fuck we made 71 we're at 130k okay Let me look at this
right now.
130k.
Okay, at 150, we get the...
We get...
My human dad will stream on his PS5 free.
So we've currently hit...
Okay, we have...
Okay, we've done the Twitter profile.
We've announced...
We've done that.
And I need to keep track of everything I've done.
I can't believe I did so.
many things already and it's only been four hours we've uh
we've did the hot sauce we did that i can get i i'm so i'm
going i can get forklift certified um okay if dinner and i
already talked about what song we're doing that one chat
doesn't decide guys we already figured out what chat what
song If we hit 60k on the Tiltify, I'll announce the song
that we're doing.
I'll let you guys know if we hit 60k at the Tiltify, you
guys will know what song we're doing.
It's just that easy.
Oh, no.
$60.
What do we do?
Oh, no.
I know you guys want to know.
Aren't you guys curious?
Oh, it's like, it's like added.
Okay, it's like, uh, we actually, uh, we, we're adding the
auction amount.
That's why I asked for, like, what the, how much we made on
the auction.
Uh, because we're adding the auction amount to the, uh
tiltify to the to the stretch goals for this so even though
it says 59 uh 59k oh it's almost there holy shit it almost
there oh my god miku thank you so much for 500 oh my god
thank you oh my god thank you oh all right all right we are
going to okay i need i don't i need to remember what the
name is called it's a pokemon song it's a pokemon song so i
need i need i don't remember the actual name
oh it's one two three after the rain um with ditto that is
the song where we're singing um Apparently I'm singing
Soraru.
Is that his name?
Yeah, I'm
But that is The do I cover that I'll be doing With Ditto!
There you guys go!
Now you know!
Alright, Dextra not taking me And 1, 2, 3 With Ditto Yeah,
my two cover songs.
Alright, that is That is the two songs.
Alright, thank you guys.
More money raised.
Well, to be fair, more people are using the money a bit on
the auction.
Because it's like a physical item that they can get.
Let's see.
I'm just trying to see what else can we do.
Before, like, we actually do stuff.
It's just been me talking to you for, like, four hours.
What the fuck?
Not important?
Wait, how do I get a forklift certification?
Forklift certification.
How do I do that?
Okay, forklift certification.
Everything you need to know.
What counts as a for- How do I get that?
Contact us today.
Okay, offers a...
training course do i have to be there do i have to be there
like i need to know how do i actually have to be there to
get a certificate i cannot just take a test okay forklift
certification test there must be a way where i can just pay
and just get a random certificate in connecticut or
something like there has to be a state that would just let
me like even though i'm canadian i know i know i'm canadian
but there has to be a state that's corrupted enough to just
let me pay to have a certain
that's illegal there has to to be one stay.
It's okay.
I'll only be able to legally drive a forklift.
There.
Tokey, please.
Forklifting is serious business.
How dare you.
How fucking dare you.
Forklifting is serious.
Why would you illegally want it?
How fucking dare you donkey
I don't know what you're talking about I don't know what
you're talking about alright guys oh shit what the fuck when
did we get 62k I was talking about ducky forklifts and we
got the 62k oh my god thank you guys that's crazy oh my god
cancelled by forklift operations on Twitter.
What are you gonna do?
Cancel me because of charity?
That's fucked up.
If they cancel me, I'll just be like, you hate charity.
Yeah, what can they do after that?
They get canceled me?
It's all about the charity!
That's fucked up.
Alright, let's see.
I'm trying to like see what's next after this.
Oh my god, we can actually do something All right, guys We
can actually play something We're at the point where we can
We don't have to talk anymore, chat We finally hit it We've
reached the point Where we can actually play something Oh my
god, we've made it It took us four hours Really made it Oh
shit But the pull, oh shit, okay, don't worry Tomboy won,
okay The next one, the next official outfit Will be Tomboy
The four hour Ad is over Would it be fucked up if I made You
guys watch me play Supermarket Simulator That would be
pretty much I wouldn't Guys, I swear I would not I'm not
gonna make you guys would not make you guys watch me play
supermarket simulator uh for even for charity that's gonna
be on my schedule next week do not worry that would be it's
do not worry chap that will be its own thing so do not worry
about that anyway actually i'm gonna check the auction real
quick before we actually play anything um oh we can oh we
can play for okay let me we can do forklift let's get our
forklift uh certification on on the internet forklift okay
we'll get a forklift um certificate on the internet um which
is the best forklift simulator guys i
guys which is the best forklift game in on steam i need to
know okay burst best forklift operator no that's This one
says 196 reviews.
They deserve to be called.
Okay, can I get a certificate that allows you to visit three
warehouses?
This game was in early access for five months?
Oh my god.
Wait, is that an actual game?
What is this?
This is not Forklift.
This is a martial artist game.
Who keeps saying shit?
What is this game?
I'm talking about forklifts.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay.
There is.
There is one.
We have.
Okay.
This is called best forklift operator.
Wait.
Is this only in VR?
No.
Okay.
This can be played.
This can be played on PC.
Okay, let me double check.
Warehouse forklift, forklift and box.
All right, I'm going to buy this.
I'm spent, I need you guys to know.
I'm literally spending $25 in containers
to play forklift simulator.
Okay, it's not forklift simulator.
It is not forklift simulator.
It's like, it's called What is it called?
Fuck, what is this called?
It's called Best Forklift Operator.
And I will be paying...
I'm gonna pay...
Pay $25 for this.
I just need to remember what my password is.
And I need to make sure I don't say it out loud.
Okay.
Yeah, remember my password real quick, guys.
Alright.
It's okay.
Thank God.
for a password manager.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That would be very unfortunate if you guys had a password
for that.
That would be so unfortunate.
Alright.
I'm gonna be the best forklift operator out there.
And then...
And then I'll take an actual test.
I need to know for sure if I'm good at this.
Okay, guys, like, I need to know for sure that this is, that
I would pass.
If I do it now, if I do it now, I'll be, like, prepared for
the actual written test.
Okay, let me down.
I need to down.
Did I not buy it?
Oh, my God.
Did I forget?
I fucking forgot to buy.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, yeah, okay.
Agree and pay.
We're doing it live.
I forgot to agree to the terms of service.
So I never bought it.
I never bought it because I forgot to create the terms of
service.
All right.
Install content.
Nice.
It's a gigabyte.
Holy fuck.
Why the fuck is the forklift operator?
Eight gigabytes.
What is in there?
Are they Bitcoin mining?
All right.
Let me go to solo gaming real fast.
Solo gaming.
Boop.
All right.
There we go.
I can't believe.
Forklift simulator.
Okay, but forklift simulator 2023 has terrible reviews.
We need to be properly trained.
We can't cheese the system.
Because when I said, why can't I just pay to have, why can't
I just pay to get the degree?
People were like, no.
Forklifting is serious business, guys.
So of course, because it's serious business, of course I
wouldn't try.
and do i will pay for the most expensive one is this not
what you wanted you guys were like whoa you can't cheap out
on this whoa doki we're ashamed of you for cheaping out
all right here we go You're gonna watch me be the best
forklift operator out there for charity.
This is my content now.
Gaming.
It's not WillQuest.
It's forklift operator.
There's a leaderboard?
Why is there a leaderboard for this?
Who's gonna...
There's gonna be someone better than me?
Do you want to play it?
Sure.
Welcome to the tutorial mode.
Before you become the best forklift operator, you have to
know how to steer a forklift.
Let's learn the basis of forklifted.
Driving in...
Alright.
What is this?
What is square?
What is...
This is mouse and keyboard.
Why is this?
No.
Please.
Why is this not?
Why is this not mouse and keyboard?
What is square?
Oh, okay.
Be careful and control your current progress.
Next to press it, can you add number of crashes?
In carrier mode, on the right, you can find information
about earned money.
If you need a break, just pause the game.
What is lines?
What's a line?
Go straight ahead using if you need to stop, press X.
What is X?
What?
What is that?
We're forklifting, guys.
This is serious.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Ow, okay.
It's okay.
I didn't hurt too much.
Alright, wait.
Do I need to drive in the straight line?
Can I just...
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I don't get penalties.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna lower...
I'm gonna lower this.
How do I reverse?
I can't reverse.
Okay, don't...
My PlayStation isn't plugged in!
How do I reverse?
I can't lower it.
This is as low.
Guys.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm going to be the best forklift operator out
there.
I have a feeling.
I have.
I'm getting a good choice.
Guys.
I have a feeling.
is gonna i might as well just bribe somebody for charity if
i tell him it's for charity do you think he'll give me a
certificate i'd be 25 for this i can't plug in my control
there it is okay okay here you go nice controller plugged
controller plugged whoa whoa oh oh oh i'm doing it i'm doing
it oh nope nope nope how do i drive back okay drive back no
that's honking please whoa where am i
please reverse reverse
reverse oh my god wait we're gonna figure this out gamepad
forklift up acceleration break there's no reverse there's
actually no wait is the transmission change left stick
button it has to be it has to be okay
am I am I doing it am I am I doing it
Please Reverse Please Okay, I'm gonna restart I'm gonna
restart Don't worry, I'm gonna get Forklift Certification
right here Alright, nice Okay Start Alright At top, left
side Next to the palette Number of crashes Use carrier mode
Okay, you go straight ahead If you need to stop Press X Okay
Oh, there we go Okay, we're doing this.
Am I going reverse?
Why am I not going reverse?
Why am I not?
Oh!
I'm going reverse!
Oh, I figured it out!
I figured it out!
Guys!
It's okay.
We don't need to follow this anymore.
Use...
Okay, we need to do that.
And then...
No.
Come on, Doki.
You gotta pass that test, Doki.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now reverse.
Oh, wait, what?
Okay.
Alright, now.
Now, up it go.
Up it go!
Oh my god!
Worklift certification is so easy.
Oh my god.
Why do you need a license for this?
A child can do it.
Ow.
Okay.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter.
They're not that expensive anyway.
Okay.
To better support the pallets.
So supported already.
Okay.
We need to put this.
We gotta put it here.
Alright.
And then we go forward.
Gaming.
Okay.
And then we...
up it goes and then oh my god I'm so fucking good at this
game okay and then reverse wait get out how does how do I
let it leave leave no no no no leave leave my fucking thing
okay guys oh oh leave leave Leave!
It has to fall eventually!
Leave!
Why is it gravity?
Why is it gravity working?
Gravity!
It wouldn't leave.
I'm reversing!
stuck why am i stuck what is stuck what is stuck oh oh wait
i'm out i'm out i'm out i'm out i'm out it worked i did it
okay wait did i do it yeah yeah i missed what do you mean
it's clearly on the thing Oh, does it have to be
specifically a lie?
This is so...
No, no, please.
Why is it like this?
Please.
Alright.
I think I'm ready.
I think the tutorial has taught me enough.
Honestly.
I think I'm ready for like...
think i'm ready for level one i think i think i think i'm
ready for grudge if i successfully get 500 um with only five
within eight minutes then i'm forklift certified i will
actually take a test for forklift certification though i
would actually do it but like But, like, I have to play this
game first to see my potential.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, come on.
Okay, we'll reverse.
And then...
We'll put it all the way down.
And then stick it in the hole.
Stick it in the hole.
Why aren't you...
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to line the forklift.
Okay.
In the hole you go.
There you go.
Alright, where do I go now?
Guys, where was I supposed to go?
Do I just...
Do I just put it in there?
I forgot.
What was my job?
Guys, what was my job?
Do I...
Do I just put it...
What was my job?
I don't remember.
That's too busy.
Is it here?
Do I take it outside?
Oh, this wasn't the thing I was supposed to do.
Oh, wait, this isn't even the item.
Okay, okay, get off.
Get off.
Okay, nice.
No, no, no, no, no.
Fuck, okay.
Okay, four more collisions.
That's okay.
This wasn't the original item.
The item's outside.
All right.
If I get one box, guys, if I manage to succeed at putting
this box up there that's all we need oh nice nice okay where
am i all right oh oh no please no how am i supposed to feed
charity no guys how am i supposed to do charity guys i don't
understand okay wait wait this is it i just need one item i
just need one item that's all i need it does not matter as
long as i get one item okay okay i'm gonna reverse i'm gonna
line this better it's all about one item.
Alright.
Oh.
Down you go.
Down.
Okay.
Come on.
Get in the hole.
I need to be forklift certified.
This is it.
Come on.
Please.
No.
Why?
Where is it?
Where?
Okay.
This has to be it.
Is it up?
Oh my god, please.
Okay, if I go down more and then...
Why?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
All right.
There we go.
No.
It's underneath!
What else do you want from me?
Okay.
Okay, I'm slowly dragging it.
All right.
And we go forward.
Oh, wait, wait.
It's up.
Oh, my God.
I'm holding it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm trying to...
I'm looking at my real...
Rear view mirror!
Okay.
My rear view mirror.
Why am I not there?
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We haven't had any collision.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
All right, that's okay.
One is fine.
One collision is fine.
We're not perfect.
All right, here we go.
And then we put it over there.
Why is there this one box blocking my way?
Get out.
Get this box out of here.
nice and then we put it here and then we we tuck it out okay
reverse i'm stuck i'm stuck please please please just let me
out let me out let me just place one oh oh that's all i ask
no no no i just want to put one in there okay and then oh my
god please please please just go in the hole put it down and
rotate are you the one oh wait wait it's off it's off okay
all right just leave leave that's off no no no no no no no
no no anyway i think
I think like, I think I'm, I think like judging by how good
I was at this, um, uh
Guys, I think like after seeing how good I was at, at, you
know, online, I feel like online with the ability of we're
so we're so locked in honestly like judging by like my
hand-eye coordination online with forklifts like I feel like
I honestly feel like if I took the test right now I could I
I could easily get forklift certified
I am I am like 100% so fucking confident that like judging
from like the simulation there is no way I could fail the
test like I feel like I felt like I was a fucking prodigy
I don't know about you But I felt like a fucking prodigy.
Sorry, I did not eat some chicken.
I had to...
Not because of the forklift.
That stress ate, guys.
Guys.
Just want you guys to know.
I was not stress eating because of the forklift.
I was just...
I was just very hungry.
Okay, it has no...
Correlation.
Guys, there was no correlation between me eating the chicken
and operating the fork lip.
No correlation at all.
I feel like...
I feel like I can do it.
I feel like after seeing my progress and operating that,
it's not that difficult.
It's like driving a car, which I haven't drove in like 10
years, but it's like driving a car.
I haven't touched a car in 10 years like you know behind the
driver's seat but I'm pretty sure it's like riding a bicycle
which I also haven't ridden in 20 years but it's like
walking
so handling a forklift it's almost as an equivalent to
walking i can feel it honestly it's gonna be so easy it's
gonna be so easy there's nothing to worry about there's
absolutely nothing to worry about i don't know why you guys
are are freaking out right now it's so simple let's check on
the auction real quick guys please don't judge me here this
is a judge-free zone this is absolutely a judge-free zone
right now so it's pretty fucked up if you're judging
please please stop judging oh my gosh all right where was i
okay Okay, okay, I actually Um Um Actually was planning on
doing the stream For another hour So Um, I will let you guys
Pick what you want to do For the last hour
Because my My stream stamina Is going down now Okay
So, this time, I'm not doing the forklift thing again,
because I know I'm a prodigy.
I know I'm a prodigy right now.
I could do a custom server for you guys in Apex, if that's
what you guys really want.
Is that what you guys want?
You guys want a custom server?
We'll do one regular game, and one regular game, and one fun
game.
I think, I don't know what a fun game would be.
always been so fun.
I fucking love the man.
Alright, guys.
We'll do two games of Apex.
Guys.
Let me swap over.
Let me boot up Apex real fast.
Apex time.
It's Apex!
Alright.
Apex time.
I haven't played Apex in a while.
I should have told her about my When did I last touch Apex?
Alright, but um...
Okay, we gotta turn down the volume, though.
Alright.
Apex.
Apex leggings.
Alright, let's see.
This one.
The first game will be serious.
Okay, create a match.
Alright, you guys ready?
I'm gonna, you guys have to type the, oh wait, I was gonna
say, you guys won't be able to see the code, because every,
all my overlays are covering up the fucking game.
I didn't know the code.
All right, three, two, one.
Boop.
Here's the code.
So I need to remember to, uh, need to remember to turn, this
time I actually will turn off the audio.
I don't trust you guys.
I don't trust you guys So I made sure that I didn't You
think you can You have the privilege Get all the top donors
And then No, that'll be so fucked up I think I'll let you on
my team You're not top five donors I won't do that I won't
do that That's so fucked up for me to do That's so up guys
i'm not guys guys it was a joke it was i swear it was a joke
guys it was a joke me all right i will do two games we'll do
two games this is why the system is the way it was wait
you're both controller wait okay i forgot i can analyze the
situation.
Oh, shit, Cameron!
Oh,
my God.
I'm just scouting, guys.
I am just...
I'm just... I'm scouting!
I'm just scouting the scenario.
Guys!
I'm just...
just trying to scout out like what what what did I do what
did I do chat I don't understand what what did I do I was
just analyzing oh is analyzing wrong now
when was that illegal chat when was that illegal to do I
don't know what you're talking about alright let's see I'm
gonna help put you guys in teams real fast alright we have
we have a few more spaces left we have well okay let's put
you guys in here we have two more spaces we have one space
left chat oh one more space and then alright this will be a
regular game.
We'll do World's Edge because it's my favorite.
Namaste mode of Amos' self-assigned team.
Allow all.
Battle royale trios.
Gun run.
Team death.
Okay.
Yes.
Alright.
Alright guys.
There we go.
We're gonna start a match in 3, 2, 1.
I don't remember how to play.
I don't even know what's meta.
Wait, no I do.
It's Bloodhound!
Wait, is it Bloodhound?
this is like caustic some shit it's like bloodhound oh wait
here you're so lucky you're so lucky i stopped for you all
right this is it
i'm sorry i didn't have a long stream stamina um really the
whole thing i really wanted to focus on was the auction
itself uh Like, a lot of the energy in.
And it was put on organizing the auction.
But I still hope you guys enjoy the stream so far.
Of just, like, hanging out.
Knowing about.
Oh, shit.
Fuck.
I heard Costic was meta now.
Or is Bloodhound meta?
I don't remember.
Doki, we have no teammate.
Well.
Sucks to be you.
I'm working on what do you want me to do
All right
All right guys Jump or kick Cameron I swear to God If you do
not be jump master If you do not be jump If none of you guys
be jump master I will end this game right now
I will stop this game right now if none of you jump I will
swap you away from my team I will fucking find another
master's player I can analyze again I like how I've jumped
fucking emotes now
Piccadocchi.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about, but I'm just saying.
Like, I wouldn't... I didn't mean I would do it now.
Like, I could...
Alright.
We're fine.
Everything will be fine.
If you guys didn't know, if you see, like, a...
Um...
If you see, like, a crow near you, um, it means there's no
one near you.
Uh, crows usually are meant for, like, far far away but they
know where the general direction is they're just not close
by so like I'm not too worried about that R9 fucking sucks
though fuck man I wish the R9 is better those poor teammates
they should be honored what do you mean all right I don't
want to okay we can we need like better armor wait do we
have anybody that can yen oh wait what okay who the fuck is
over there right now what are you doing what are you doing
huh what are you doing what are you doing did he actually
land the wrong area
bro wait he's solo go Cameron go Cameron don't be a little
pussy your masters Players, play your part.
Woo!
Okay, I didn't see him.
I did not see him.
Look, I didn't die, though.
Okay, this teammate's coming over.
Guys, this teammate's coming.
No, he's won!
He's literally won!
Guys, I swear to God, he's literally...
Guys!
I swear to you guys!
You fuck.
Oh my god.
Please.
Thirst him.
Please thirst him for me.
Okay.
Alright, we're okay.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
everything is fine there's nothing to worry about where is
the guy we oh what the fuck okay nothing maybe not that fine
now wait where is the guy we thirsted can we not thirst him
do we not okay why is there so many people on us all right i
don't want to i don't feel so good here where's the vantage
where the fuck is the It's over here.
Okay, I'm gonna scan.
We scan.
He can't vantage all of us.
Guys, guys, you have to remember.
There we go.
Okay, are you guys ready?
We go in together.
Go.
There's no way he can vantage all of us.
I am a firm believer of that.
There's no way.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Run, you little bit.
that's fucking right you run you little coward i have oh i'm
faster than you what the are you doing though like
please okay i couldn't hit the fucking last shot i knew i
knew you You couldn't run forever.
Okay, wait, Raven's charge.
Okay, that's good.
Look, I haven't used the...
Oh!
Guys, guys, guys, guys!
Guys!
Alright, nice.
It's okay.
I have to heal here.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Alright.
We are okay.
We're in zone.
all right this is fine this is so fine you're on the high
ground that'll be so fucking cool if i landed that i got if
only if only
my champion oh don't die okay there's three men chilling
down there oh res res res res i'll cover cover.
Res, res, res.
Res, I can cover this.
I can cover this.
Go high ground.
Say high ground.
They're coming down the stairs.
They're right down the stairs.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Please, for the love of god.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Literally one guy left.
wait where is he where the fuck what where do you get shot
where what what you guys got shot
you might be behind us i cannot res guys i don't know where
he is and that's why i'm scared i know i don't know where he
is guys No hostile?
Where the fuck is he?
Wait, they res'd.
Oh my god, they res'd!
Okay.
They're like back there.
Alright guys, guys, we have to camp these bodies so they get
nothing.
That is our goal.
We gotta make sure they don't get anything.
Here, here, you're so low.
Here, take this Phoenix kit.
Here.
Oh, wait, he's here.
That's a whole team.
Wait, that's a different team.
Wait a minute.
This is... Do we have... Okay.
I'm going to do something extreme.
Guys, okay, guys.
Dude, guys, I'm leaving.
Guys, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Guys, guys, I'm...
Guys, take the zip!
It's the only way!
I swear, it's the only way.
You have to take the zip.
It's the only way.
Just don't die.
Okay, we leave.
Come over here!
Dude, leave!
There's so many people!
Come on!
Guys, we have to go!
We have to go the zone!
I can't babysit you forever!
okay there's people to my left okay we're gonna oh there's
people behind me guys we just leave just head to the fucking
zone who cares who cares we just need to go to zone just run
that's all i care it's okay we're fine we're so healthy
wait there's a package
my crow never mind okay we take the zip guys guys we take a
zip and then we leave again there should be nobody near me
because i scanned a crow all right we go here there should
be nobody there right all right guys i'm so hopeful for us
Hi.
Okay, I'm so fucking hopeful.
What the fuck?
No, my package!
Fuck, okay, my package.
It's okay, we're in center zone.
We're center zone.
There's nothing that could go wrong.
Except for these guys who might get, like, Krabber or some
shit.
So I don't...
I'm actually a little scared.
We might get Krabbered.
Alright.
It's okay.
We're top 10!
That's so good for us.
It's okay!
Wait a minute.
I hear something.
I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure there's nobody behind me.
Please.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting over here.
Does anyone have a sniper?
I can barely see what's going on.
Alright.
It's fine.
I want to thirst this guy, but he's so fucking far.
God damn it.
I'm so close to thirsting him.
No, he's so close.
I can't hit your shot.
You know what?
Good for you.
I'm glad you hit your shot.
I'm happy for you.
All right.
All right, we're good.
Okay, we're in zone.
We're in zone.
Nothing to worry about.
Okay, I gotta grab that.
I'm going to make sure there's nobody behind us, too.
That's what I'm worried about.
I need to make sure my backs are free from anybody that
wants to third us.
I'll take the redeploy.
Where's the redeploy?
There's people to my right.
Oh my god, he was flesh!
That guy was fucking flesh!
We're in zone, we're in zone.
We're in zone.
We don't have to worry.
Wait, what?
I don't need that real fast.
No, it's fine.
It's okay.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy right now.
It's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
I need energy.
Do you guys have energy?
Oh my god, we're all running energy.
Why are we all running energy?
Why are we all?
Guys, that was not very smart.
of us.
Wait, what?
Where?
Too hostile.
Above us!
We got a wall.
Okay, they're right above us.
Put walls!
Cameron!
Use your master skills and put up walls!
Wait, what?
What?
Wait, did they put up the redeploy?
Oh, we're not there.
Guys, we can steal their redeploy.
Guys, we steal their redeploy.
Guys.
Come, come, come, come, come, come.
We steal their redeploy.
It's ours now.
We have to go this way.
Alright, guys, guys, guys, come here, come here, come here.
Come here.
we go in the tunnel
fight this fight this fight this
all right we're fine we're fine we're so fucking fine we're
so healthy we're so healthy wait did they win this already
no i don't have nades i don't have nades i can't do anything
i can't do anything about it I can't do anything about it.
Don't have names.
Break the door.
Break the door with your rampart art.
Trust me.
You have rampart art.
Break it.
It's okay.
Never mind then.
Alright, nice.
I can't see jack shit, but okay.
I'm gonna heal now.
I can't see anything.
Alright.
We're getting altered.
Guys, come back to me.
come back to me, guys.
I don't want to do this anymore.
We go in the tunnel.
Trust me.
Trust.
Come back!
Come back, Race!
Don't be a hero!
I'm gonna thirst him, though.
Race!
No!
Don't be a hero!
Okay, he's fucked.
We can't save him.
Like, there's no way.
There's no way we can save this, man.
There's no way.
I'm gonna I'm going to give you a Q in three seconds.
There is...
On the roof?
We can kill him on the roof, actually.
Yeah, knock one guy.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, dead, dead, dead, dead, full dead.
Full dead, full dead.
I picked him up.
Go res, go res him.
They're all dead.
Res, res, res, res.
We have res.
Go be a hero.
Res this man.
Shall take the...
I'll take this, actually.
Okay, don't be a hero, maybe.
Maybe don't be a hero.
I only have five energy ammo.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Are you resing him?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, do not res him yet.
There's people here.
You're free.
You're free to res.
Trust me.
No one will know.
Cameron, be a hero.
Trust me.
Cameron, trust me.
Be it.
Trust me.
No one will know.
I swear to God.
no one will know see
I told you they didn't know I told you no one knew he needed
to trust me I told you no one will know go grab his
told you guys no one will know like it was so nice i'm gonna
bat oh no okay we don't have any res beacons here guys oh no
no one will know all right let's see
side i got thirded so hard no that's right you deserve it
get thirsty I got shot in the side.
No!
I did so much.
What happened, Cameron?
Did you not plug in your controller?
I analyzed you.
Cameron!
I analyzed you, Cameron!
Cameron give me your excuse right now what happened I need
to know Cameron tape and chat what is your excuse in chat no
stream delay yeah let me put a stream delay on this.
You confused him.
This is him.
I got snipe.
Someone please kill this man.
He's literally solo.
Run at him.
He has nothing.
Just beat him up with your fist.
He's solo.
Oh my god.
Punch him.
Punch him!
Cameron for goal.
He for goal.
He for real.
GG's.
GG's, guys.
GG's, everybody.
Alright, we will do one more game.
We'll do one last game.
But, like, this time.
This time, it will be melee only.
You cannot use any damn...
No damaging abilities.
Guys, okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna leave custom match.
And then I'm gonna create.
Private match.
Create.
It's the same...
Is this the same code?
Okay.
Alright.
No damaging abilities.
Guys.
Melee only.
No damaging abilities.
And you can punch people out.
This calls for Olympus because I want the car.
I want the car.
Alright.
I don't have to analyze anybody here.
I don't have to analyze anyone.
what all right okay no damaging abilities melee only melee
only chat okay melee only let me put you guys into teams
real quick boop boop and then boop and I'll put you guys in
observers.
Remember.
Melee only.
No damaging abilities.
Okay.
We gotta get a car.
Guys, we gotta get a car.
Guys, we have to get a car.
We can't let them.
We gotta get a car, guys.
Team.
We gotta get a car, team.
No.
Yes, guys.
cars.
Yes, cars.
Guys, I'm literally the host.
You can't say no cars.
I'm literally the host right now.
Chat, you can't say that to me.
You can't say that.
I'm literally the host.
Okay.
One V... No.
Guys, no.
Okay.
Fuck.
What would be a good no damaging ability?
What would be a good one?
Octane.
I can self-heal.
Wait.
Okay.
Guys.
Yes.
Newcastle.
That's a good idea.
Just keep resing me.
We can't die.
We can't.
If you both keep resing me.
Oh my god.
We should have played Horizon.
guys just do not just keep resing me and then we can win
this all right we gotta think this we gotta we gotta be able
to think this strategically okay okay where's guys the car
guys right here the car we gotta get that car guys our only
mission right now is to grab the car.
That's all we need.
We need the car.
Oh, you.
All right.
Wait, where's the car?
Oh, here.
I fucking couldn't find the car for some reason.
All right, we go.
We go.
Grab the car.
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I like stalled for...
Oh, my God.
Did I got like grift or something?
guys okay i forgot we could have put a pathfinder too it's
okay we're good nice all right we got everything and i don't
know what the plan is anymore all right guys that was the
extent of my plan now i don't i guess we loot for heals wait
they have cars too what all right guys go loot heals guys go
loot some heals right now loot heals we need heals do your
thing there's no plan b there's another car okay i'm gonna
take you guys to the second car all right i'm gonna take you
guys to the second car all right one guy loot heals here and
then we'll pick you up later that's all right all right all
right newcastle come here second plan b get another car wait
loot this loot this lifeline click this right now lifeline
Click this Yeah Oh shit we gotta go We gotta go We gotta go
We gotta get the second car Who got the second car?
We gotta get the third car It's all the way over there But
it's okay We can do this We can make it We can grab We can
grab the third car It's possible Okay how do we Intercept
you?
Okay we gotta go from here Okay, we gotta grab that third
car.
It's okay.
A little zone damage wouldn't hurt anybody.
We'll be fine like plan.
Plan B.
Step number two, two cars.
Step number two.
Who grabbed this car?
Who keeps grabbing the cars?
Wait, I actually got off.
Guys, sorry.
Guys, get back out.
It was an accident.
Oh, we need that.
Actually, grab that.
Grab the yellow thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
There's still another car here.
Grab this.
Alright.
Newcastle.
Yes, blue armor.
Alright.
We gotta get that car.
Wait, what do I need?
What is this?
Takes 20...
Oh, hey, nice.
This didn't damage.
Alright.
Number two.
There's still... What happened?
There's still that car.
The car is still there.
You can't get that car!
We get that car!
first.
Wait, where is it?
It's still there.
All right.
Who's going to get... Who's going to have... Who has a
driver's license?
Guys, who has a driver's license?
Nice.
All right.
Now we grab the yellow things.
There has to be another yellow.
All right.
We grab this.
This.
Step three.
Okay, I'll grab it, I'll grab it.
Okay, step three, we split up.
We split up and grab the yellow boxes until we're red armor.
I go for this.
Oh my god, this is like the most ingenious plan.
We're totally gonna...
Guys, we split up.
Guys, you don't have to follow me anymore.
We split up and grab until we're red armor.
Guys, this is our ingenious plan.
What the fuck?
How did... What?
Was there a jump pad there?
Wait, how do we get that?
Where the fuck is the yellow box here?
Is it underneath?
Oh, no, there's a melee guy here.
Okay, I can't be here, guys.
Step three failed.
I need to find another yellow box.
Oh, here.
It's okay.
It didn't work.
Look, I didn't account for them not allowing cars, okay?
for that instructions were a little bit unclear there that
there was like you know another car like another team and it
doesn't allow cars i'm gonna go for that one all right here
we go nice nice we're we're close to purple we can do this
we can get red so easy all right we'll go for that one
there's no way somebody will steal my car there's no fucking
way i swear to guys someone from high ground just yonks my
car.
I swear to fuck.
That would be so fucked up.
I'll go grab this one.
Don't worry, I got this.
Step five, ditch car.
No, no, no, no, no.
Cars are forever.
Wait, I can scan this.
God has a book.
Okay, we can't use that.
Where is it?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Guys, can we like work?
Why can we be friends?
Yeah, you're like, cool.
Thanks, guy.
It's like a...
You're just like...
Okay, that's just so fucking...
Okay, there.
The try-through.
Alright, we have all the yellow stuff.
Okay.
There's one over here.
I'm just figuring out how to get there.
What he just...
He was just like, hey, you also getting those yellow things?
Yeah!
Actual paid actor.
Oh my god, look at them.
Is this also a taxi ride?
Okay.
That poor team that's getting punched up.
Hey, are we all going for this one too?
Hey guys.
Are we all...
I'm part of your team too.
Hey guys, are you also trying to get that?
Don't worry.
I'll wait for you guys, too.
You guys go first.
You guys go.
You first, guys.
You guys.
Wait, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
This has to do.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, okay.
Are you guys?
Are you guys gonna let me pick that up?
to pick that up too come on come on you guys had your turn i
just had your turn come on come on guys come on you guys had
your turn it's my turn now all right nice nice peace of love
look at that oh wait whoops the wrong one that's so sweet of
them to like take turns i really i really appreciate it my
mom said it's my turn for red shields i i really do
appreciate that they were willing to uh that we that we took
turns there it's really nice uh i'm glad i'm glad we could
all work together and uh take our turn grabbing grabbing
those red It's really nice and appreciated.
Boop.
Alright, we're in zone.
We're in zone.
The very peaceful fight.
Well, I mean, it's not that peaceful.
Wait, wait.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's not that peaceful.
There's like three teams already died, chat.
Three teams.
Wait, did they lose the car?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Did they lose the car?
What do you mean?
Oops.
What?
what happened I swear if I come back and there's no cars
what happened guys guys we worked so hard to get those cars
I kept guys what happened all right punch them you guys can
punch them when you're in the car Punch them!
Punch them back!
Come on!
That's what you're right.
You get dead!
It's like pay play.
Come on.
Punch them!
Punch them is one guy!
Okay, wait, first let me get closer.
Guys, it's one guy.
You guys can do this.
Guys, please.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm struggling too.
guys oh shit red armor we got this we're so fucking ready
we're so ready all right they can't drive away forever okay
punch him yeah yeah get him get him get him get him get him
let him rip come on you can't run away forever just keep
meleeing you got this yes melee these guys Yes!
Woohoo!
It's okay.
That's okay.
We can Beyblade this.
These fucking cars.
It's so stupid.
What episode of Beyblade this?
Let it rip.
Hey, faster.
Sonic.
It's like Beyblade and Sonic.
Come on.
It's literally one guy!
You can do this!
You can do this, team!
Just keep meleeing!
Thank you, Haveron!
Oh my god, yes, yes, here, here, here!
This is it!
Keep punching!
That's right, he's one guy.
There's no way.
There's no way he can fuck around.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Wait, melee this guy.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, this guy.
Whoa!
It's okay.
I hope you guys are fucking...
I hope you guys are fucking fucking...
We're almost to the end.
It's okay.
Who scanned?
Why do you need to scan?
We're in melee only.
Don't worry.
We're red armor.
None of them have red armor like us.
None of them are as good as us, guys.
Look at all these cards.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
That's it!
Keep punching!
Guys, good.
Never stop punching.
Never stop.
Just keep going.
Oh, right here.
We can, like, heal ourselves here, too.
Are you guys punching?
I hope you guys are punching.
I hope you guys are... Why did you get off?
Why did you guys get off?
We're doing so well.
We're getting free heals.
Guys, I hope you guys are punching.
I hope... Don't worry, we're getting free heals right now.
We're getting...
No shit, no, can't shit me.
Don't worry.
Come back in here.
Heal, heal.
You guys go heal yourself.
Go heal!
You need to shield yourself.
Alright, nice.
It's okay, everything is fine.
Who made a fucking hut here?
Okay, this is our new home.
Here we go.
Nobody can hit us here.
Go heal.
Wait, I need to heal.
Alright, guys.
I'm going to heal real fast.
Stay on the ship.
Stay on here so nobody can steal it.
It's okay.
We can't let anybody steal it.
It's fine.
Nobody can reach the top.
Nobody can reach the rock.
We're so safe No, no, nobody can reach it It's our base
defense.
We're gonna surf real fast.
Okay, you got yeah Yeah, oh shit you gotta drive us closer
now.
All right, my turn to melee mom said it's my turn Don't
worry Don't worry.
We need to be on the ring.
We need to be in the ring We need to be in the ring guys
Guys, please We need to be in the ring So we're almost there
Alright, this is gonna be fine I feel safe I feel very safe
Wait Wait, who's punching us?
It's okay, I feel very safe still I have zero shields, by
the way, guys Wait, wait, I'm gonna craft, I'm gonna craft
shields I'm gonna craft shields, don't get off the car It's
okay, they can't punch me We're okay, fine Wait, who got off
the car?
Okay Nice, nice.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Look at all these cars.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna get off the car.
You guys stay in the car?
You guys stay in the car.
I'm gonna do something crazy.
We'll be fine.
This is our defense.
Alright, if we can...
What?
Okay, we can literally...
This is our defense.
Wee!
He cat hurt us.
We're in the air.
Yay.
Yippee.
Our little bouncy castle defense.
Whoa!
Yay.
Yippee.
This is the thing this is what devs wanted This is what devs
wanted This is the true purpose of apex legends Right here
Right here Peak apex gaming Peak apex gaming Okay guys guys
I'm gonna get off the card Make sure the card is safe I
think I have another I think I have another another alt.
Okay, 89.
Never mind.
Car!
Woo!
Shit.
Guys, someone else getting, someone else drive.
Someone else drive.
Okay.
I need to know my alt.
Okay, okay, guys, guys.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna give ourselves another one.
Right here.
There we go.
Safe.
Wait, where is my car?
Where is my... Yes!
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
Okay, here we go.
Another safe.
Yay!
We're okay.
We have another defense here.
Our target.
No, no, no, no.
Do not drive in the ring.
No!
It's okay.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Use the bouncy castle!
Swap, swap drivers, swap drivers.
Guys, swap drivers.
I'm a better driver.
Swap drivers Wait, where's my car?
Where's my car?
Where's the car?
Where is the car?
Wait, this works.
Stay there.
Just stay there.
You'll be safe.
Do not move.
You'll be so safe.
Just do not move.
Okay, all right, never mind.
It stopped working.
We almost had it.
We almost had it there.
We almost got it.
What could have been?
Just stay in the car.
Stay in the car and keep bouncing.
You got this.
Just stay there forever.
Oh, shit.
Shit, I thought you technically, like...
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Whoa!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Boom.
Alright.
There you go.
I have only have one bat.
I only have one bat here.
Okay, as long as I'm in the air, nothing can hurt me.
As long as I'm in...
Wait!
My car.
My car, okay.
Alright, here we go.
As long as I'm in the near, no one can hurt me.
This is the logic we're going.
No!
Tubby!
It's a team!
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
Oh, God, oh, God.
Let me...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I'm fine.
Oh, yeah.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
everything is okay everything is okay everything will be
okay everything will be clutch i told you i told you guys i
told you guys having the moment we had so many i knew it was
gonna be clutch i fucking knew i fucking knew it was gonna
be clutch right there was gonna work out having it to the
shield back the shield back the shield back if i keep
shielding if i keep shielding no no go go go
oh shit i'm gonna stand up here if they can't melee me if
i'm on top of it no
just keep just heal Josie Josie Josie oh no They were so
close They were so close Oh my god Who the fuck run Is this
the Mosh pit?
Who fucking What?
Oh he has Joki in the name Technically that means me chat he
has doki in the name that's technically me
I'm in there we take those we fucking take those chichi
holy shit I fucking love melee only melee only is always
it's always fucking chaotic as hell oh my um We take those,
guys.
GGs, everybody.
We fucking take those.
Jesus Christ.
Holy fuck.
All right.
Let's do an auction check.
An auction check, guys.
How many have we...
How many...
How much have we made so far in the auction?
Guys.
Any...
My human calculators.
Rise up.
Is your chance to shine human calculators.
Bacon, thank you so much for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
I can't believe.
I can't believe how much we've made, how much support we got
on the charity itself.
It really blows my mind.
$72,000.
oh my god that is actually insane guys thank you guys so
much i can't believe oh we raised so maybe it's like a
hundred and a forty thousand dollars that's actually um
crazy guys all i'm saying is if we get 10k if we manage to
get uh 10 more thousand dollars we can have my dad human dad
by the way stream on his ps5 for you that's what I'm saying
and we've only 10k
we're almost there alright let me actually let me do the
calculation real quick just to be sure just to be sure yes
the the father stream the father stream guys all right i'll
give you guys a choice it's either okay guys you know what
i'll even throw in an extra i'll even do the pokemon smasher
pass if you guys get there i know it's a 200k goal but i'll
even do the pokemon smasher and pass or pass if you guys get
to 10 if you guys get to 150k um we're currently at 140 so
we need uh 78 000 to have both pokemon smash or pass and the
dad stream the the dokey dad stream like that why not power
why not don't Do this to battle world.
Don't do this to battle world.
Oh!
But it has been crazy, though.
I think we raised in total almost $200,000, though.
We include the...
No Visage, though.
Thank fucking God.
Um...
I'm so happy we didn't get Visage.
Thank goodness.
All I'm saying, all I'm saying is that if I have any
billion, any billionaires son or daughter right now.
Reminding that we originally said 200k for Visage.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, you know what?
You know what, guys?
Okay, I'm going to throw you a bone.
I'm going to throw you...
Because I feel so nice right now.
I'm going to throw you guys a bone, chat.
Because I feel incredibly generous.
If...
If we hit...
On the Tiltify.
78,000...
I will play one chapter of Visage.
I'll do one chapter of the Visage.
And...
The Pokemon Smash.
Master Pass.
We're going to take away the human, my dad playing on this
PS5, streaming on this PS5.
I'm going to substitute.
I will substitute for playing Vistage one chapter.
If we hit on the Tilt of 5, on the stretch goal, 78.
Okay, okay.
I'll give you, alright.
I'll give you three.
Alright.
I feel incredibly generous right now.
We don't want you, Doki.
We want your father.
Both were gay.
How dare you take...
Okay, alright, alright.
If we hit 78,000, you get Pokemon Smash Your Pass.
You get the Dad PS5 stream.
And Visage 1.
chapter one chapter that's all I'll give you look I don't
think cuz like someone's like a hundred K on tilt to five if
for the full game look I'll entertain you guys I'll even
entertain you with this if you manage to get a hundred K on
tilt to before the stream is over.
I'll give you guys 30 more minutes.
If you manage to hit 100k on the Tiltify itself, you get the
full game.
You get the full game.
This does not include the auction, by the way.
This does not include the auction.
not enough time unfortunately what are you a quitter
how is this i that is not a scam that's not a scam i
literally went from 400k to a hundred k guys i literally
went from 400k to a that is like the the most you can ever
get that is like 70% off for my own sanity and I'm giving
you 30 minutes to reach that to be fair yeah it went down
from 400k 400k was a scam to be but it didn't turn into a
scam in the end because I lowered it down to 100k but this
does not include the auction this is does not include the
auction you have to the moment look I'll even be more
generous fine guys never say I was not nice
never say I was not generous but I'll even give you until my
OBS hits six hours until my the moment my OBS hits six hours
which is um um
which is which is like okay let me count which is in 40 I'm
giving you 40 minutes guys I'm literally giving you 40
minutes to hit that guys I'm gonna it's not fake Jitter Rob
I literally gave you a 10 minute extension what do you mean
I alright you guys debate amongst yourself I'm gonna use the
bathroom.
It's been, it's been fucking five hours.
I have not had a bathroom break.
I'm gonna be right back, chat.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't think we're gonna be hitting that 100k.
I think I was still trying to bargain.
It was like, what about $5?
Guys, I was very perfectly clear on how this is gonna go.
I don't know.
Let's Berkeley.
Let it be 80.
Okay.
90k.
Final offer.
It is five.
You cannot say it's a scam.
I literally went down from 400k.
All right.
Final offer.
You're not, you're not like weathering me down.
Like I know what you guys are trying to do.
You guys are trying to like weather me down more and more
until like I get to the number you want like you try it
don't think I don't know what you're doing right now don't
think I don't know we're 90k that is absolutely my final
offer I will not go below that there is no way we've done it
before it's called haggling yes over you have you have 30 40
35 minutes you have 35 minutes to hit 90k and with that 90k
I will fully play Visage this is there is this for charity
there's no I go
Guys, look, you have to be reasonable, guys You have to be
reasonable about my mental health For the mental health For
the brain and behavior foundation
Look, I did say I did say 78 that holy shit we did oh my god
we jumped six thousand dollars holy guys uh like how's
people like keep talking to dokey so she adds more perks
guys she's desperate guys keep talking the more we weather
her down the more she'll give us the more everything is
attainable now guys we have to keep weathering her down
she's gonna give up eventually
if everyone just donates keep stalling stop figuring this
out guys no more I will not be giving any more perks I will
not be getting no no no no no no no no no no no no no you're
not getting any more perks from me chat we've established we
have established 90k that is the lowest I will go.
That is the lowest you will bargain with me.
I'm literally Asian.
You can't out-haggle me.
There is in no possible way you can out-haggle me.
I'm literally Asian.
I lived in Asia.
I had to haggle for real there.
But only only if you get to only if you get to 90k will I
put fully play Visage.
But Oh my god, we're almost there!
Dragon's!
One cave more!
And you get the first chapter of Visage.
You get the first chapter of Visage.
And one more cave.
And then you get first chapter.
You should be proud of it.
But honestly, You guys should be proud of yourself to raise
this much money for charity.
It's actually insane how much you have guys all worked
together for such a great cause.
You know what?
Alright, hey guys.
Guys, okay, wait, let me see.
Guys, I'll give you guys, you know what?
You know what, guys, don't worry.
Let's see...
$10.
I just send in $10.
For my own charity, I just put in $10.
Don't worry guys, I'm gonna help out.
She shows weakness.
Now is our time.
No, this is not weakness!
I am helping you guys out.
Do not take this as weakness.
Do not take this as weakness, guys.
Alright.
Okay.
For charity.
I'm doing my part.
Boop.
I'll give you guys the first chapter of Vassage.
you're welcome you're you're welcome i did it for you guys i
gave you the first chapter of visage right there that's i
added an extra zero for you i could have been dead you could
have the tutorial i never said what chapter it was a
tutorial level is technically a
If you think about it Hmm Scab No The scab Okay okay okay
okay Okay okay I will do one chapter I'll do one 30 more
minutes TikTok 30 more minutes Okay Okay Okay all right
since uh all right guys since uh we're at we got the poke
okay I'm not gonna do pokemons I need to be like hanging in
the mine so I feel like I need a drink for that I feel like
guys I'm sorry I feel like I need a drink for Pokemon smash
your pass I cannot do it live right now I cannot do it live
I need a I need a drink for Pokemon Smash or Pass.
There's no fucking way I am going to be doing that sober.
There's no... I'm not drinking now.
Who the fuck named themselves Doki Scamberbird?
I literally gave 1k.
You cannot say I'm scamming.
I gave 1k to charity.
Alright.
The Pokemon, we have Visage Chapter 1.
A Pokemon Smasher Pass.
And I'm gonna do that drunk.
Because I cannot be so...
There's no way I'm gonna be sober for this.
Oh my god!
10k!
10 more k!
And then you get the full...
Okay, I'll put 95.
95?
Do we agree on that?
Okay, I know like we said 90k.
But what about 95k?
95k?
like what funny yo yo stop okay guys just just think about
it guys wouldn't it be funny if it was 95k instead of 90k no
i said 90 no no no you guys cannot gaslit me in the thinking
85 you guys cannot gaslit me thinking it was 85 90 90k not
oh wait 95 full game look the blind and death the blind and
death says 95 they agree they agree to it it that you agreed
to no no i never said 85 i never said 85 i said 90.
i said i was willing to go down 90.
now i know you guys are gaslighting me i know for a fact
that it was 90k
no no no no no no no no no no no i remember it was 90.
i remember chat you can't gaslight me You can't gaslight me
on this.
You can't gaslight me.
I swear to God.
But honestly, the amount we've accomplished today has been
amazing.
And the charity, the auction isn't even over.
The auction isn't even over.
have like guys 24 minus okay guys okay 23 22 21 20 19 18 we
just have 18 hours left out of out of the auction and the
fact that we were able to we were able to um raise so much
normally a lot of charity streams they're like 24 hours or
like multiple days but the fact that like you know the I
know like the stream itself not much was really like it was
mostly mostly focused on the auction and everything and it
was just like hanging out with you guys and just talking
about um the foundation and the items and just having like a
little hangout session with all you guys getting my forklift
simulator on before my actual forklift certification and
everything and the fact that we are able to how are you bad
at map because I'm fucking stupid I'm a streamer you think
this brain is used on numbers?
Why do you think I fucking do dumb shit for entertainment?
That's what you know.
I have no prospects in math.
Anyway, as I was saying, back to being like, fucking humble
and everything.
Back
to being, like, super humbled and generous.
Um.
as I was saying
other than the stream itself there wasn't really a lot
planned for the stream itself I just really wanted to use it
to like introduce the auction items I never really planned
on doing a very long charity stream because the full focus
was on the auction itself it was really is like an amazing
like just to see dragoons um just like you know working
together to raise so much money for such a good cause and um
being able to like and it's still going oh my god they're
fighting over the keyboard again bro and like stop but now
they're still fighting
It is trying so fucking hard for that keyboard.
Oh.
Um, but they woke up.
A new, a new challenger has arrived.
Cameron.
Cameron has woken up and is ready.
All right.
For those who are new here, I'm wondering what, what is
everyone fighting about?
Okay, don't worry, I will put the text up for all of you
guys, for you guys to know.
Alright, um, if hit 90k, I will play Visage all chapters.
Alright, here you go.
Here.
Doki's skin.
No, I'm not.
Here we go.
But only!
Only if you hit that number.
Where did the text go?
Where did it go?
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
Here.
I will only do it if I hit 90K.
I will play this.
No.
No, no, no, no.
We agreed.
90K.
90K or bust.
I, guys, if I see 85K, I see more 85Ks, I'm raising it to
95K.
Don't make me do that.
I will do it.
Guys, start playing 90K.
Or if I see more 85Ks.
I'm raising it up to 95k you can't do that don't keep that
stop this is my stream
I better see 90k's in my chat or I'm raising it to 95
and that is how you train your chat
that is how you make sure your chat is in line for the five
gifted ships.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, yeah, it's been, it's been, I'm really, I think, like,
the one thing I'm, like, super, I'm very excited to do a,
uh, to do the cover songs with both, uh, Dero and Yusun.
Um, I can't believe, I can't believe you guys knew my
favorite song was I should not have taken thee.
Oh my god.
What were the odds that you picked my favorite song for me
to do a cover?
You guys just knew me so well.
I know.
You guys just knew me so fucking well.
It's actually crazy.
How well you knew.
Like...
It is crazy how well you just know me guys.
I'm, I'm like, I'm like wow.
My true fans.
All right.
Let me double check something real quick chat.
Oh my gosh.
I need to like train back my stream stamina though.
I haven't been able to.
It's been a while since I stream for this long in I've
definitely been like pushing it a lot because I obviously
like I want to um be able to stream long hours for you guys
again and being able to do like a lot of like fun things
with you guys and plan so many fun events and everything um
but I want to say also like a huge thank you to my team my
management team mr.
man and little man for uh for helping me set all of this up
oh my gosh is actually crazy there's so much so much work
that they all did so huge shout out to them zachary thank
you for the 10 gift the chips thank you thank you i'm gonna
make sure that um i'm gonna make sure that i've done
everything on the the the stretch goals and i didn't miss
out on anything yet i'm just gonna be make sure everything
is good to go all right the only thing i need to uh make
sure that I post the community post for um what is it the
voice packs and also the bento so other than that we should
be good to go I don't think no no no no we did the hot sauce
we did the hot sauce you can't gaslight me on that I
remember what we did
daddy thank you for the 10 gift of chips thank you you thank
you i really do appreciate it thank you so much but i really
do think you guys should all be extremely proud of
yourselves to be able to um get together and um just raise
so much money so much money for such a such a good cause and
i'm just i'm just so happy i can't believe the amount of
money we've raised um in general it's just insane uh What
about the giveaway?
Okay, I'm gonna tweet out the giveaway right now.
Mr. Man actually, like, gave me the tweet draft for a while
now.
I just haven't tweeted it out.
Like, he's actually, I just haven't done it.
I just haven't.
You know how long he's given it to me?
It was two hours ago, by the way.
I received it two hours ago.
So, all right, let me tweet this out.
I'll just do a like and retweet.
You don't have to leave a...
I'll just do a like retweet.
I don't...
You guys don't have to leave a like.
To enter retweet and bark for me.
Okay.
All right, okay.
No giveaway for my debut mark as well as the upcoming...
Okay, to enter retweet and bark for me.
in the replies.
The good laugh announced.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I'm tweeting it out.
Guys, it's free!
Guys!
What do you mean?
It's free!
Guys, you can't judge me.
You can't judge me.
I can judge you guys because you're gonna bark in the
replies.
Do I keep my Twitch system That's me on Twitter.
It is for charity.
Are you trying to say you guys won't bark for charity?
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, chat.
Looked up.
All right, I'm posting it now.
Okay, let me make sure.
I'm doing giveaway for my debut merch button as well as
upcoming learn new merch button.
Tentary, retweet and bark for me.
Okay.
Like, give it.
Like, okay.
Okay.
All right, we're good.
All right, here we go.
All right, guys.
I would howl.
Exactly!
Derp knows it.
Derp is willing to howl for charity.
Be more like Derp.
Here you go.
There we go.
See, look at that.
Instant parks.
Right there.
Well, you judge all these people that burn.
in the replies instantly?
Sell.
What do you mean?
I'm not the sellout here.
Look at yourselves in the mirror.
That's right.
Look at that.
256 barks already.
chat 256 barks there you go it's just that easy it's just oh
my god 82,000 guys we're so close okay guys what's um how
many more minutes to to uh okay it's like okay wait let me
get my calculator let me get my calculator real quick 60
minus 43 17 more minutes guys 17 more minutes And you guys
will get full visage.
I will change my profile picture after the stream.
Don't worry.
I know exactly what profile picture to change, guys.
You guys were very adamant about the fucking tomato bikini.
I see it.
I see the tomato bikini.
Do not worry.
It's there.
It's there in the Twitter replies.
Do not worry.
so good it's perfect all right how long when can i turn it
okay on the 16th i can change it on 16th do i have anything
professional to do no okay we are good there's nothing
professional to do in the next two weeks so i do not have to
worry i do not have to worry it's okay there is nothing to
worry about now i wonder if i can like actually lower this
okay Let's see.
It's possible to...
Okay, we're gonna...
Oh, it is!
Nice.
Alright.
We are at...
We'll put this back at...
No!
Must be at least equal to your top.
Oh, okay.
As long as I get rid of the...
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
It's time to do some little...
Alright, we're gonna delete this...
Because we're definitely not gonna hit 400k.
We're gonna...
There's no way we're hitting that.
That's for sure.
All right, we're going to delete this.
And then we're going to put this up here.
I'm just going to fix this real fast, guys.
And then I think we're at here, right?
Yay!
We did it.
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
Is this all our milestones?
Okay, 200.
I'm just going to fix our little...
I'm just going to fix our...
Our calendar real quick.
because I can finally get rid of the 400k goal.
Toki, cheater.
There's no way you're going to hit Elden Ring.
Guys, there's no negotiating with that.
There's no more negotiating.
You're...
Wait, what?
You're not 1.3k away.
It's 7.7.
We've agreed.
We've established that you have...
You are going to hit 9k and that...
And that we have...
Okay, how much time do we have left?
46 minus 60.
There is 14 minutes left.
Okay, if you guys need 14 minutes left.
There we go.
So you guys will know how much time you guys have left for
this.
Here.
Just to make sure.
You have 14 minutes left to hit 90k.
I honestly don't think you guys...
Like, the thing is...
Um, I know you guys aren't gonna hit it.
I...
Sell your Bitcoin.
Dragon's!
This is the- This is the only way!
Sell your Bitcoin!
The doubt.
No, I'm not doubting.
I know you guys aren't gonna fucking hit 90k.
You literally have 13 minutes left.
now chat it's true yeah but this could be reverse psychology
but no matter what you're going to be doing what I want you
either not hit it and do what I want or hit it and do what I
want so like which way do you want to like spite me you're
not you're gonna not hit it and prove me right like prove me
right Or hit it and prove me wrong.
This whole system is rigged.
Well, I'm teaching you a life lesson.
No matter what you do, this whole thing is rigged.
Oh my god, 2K.
Who donated 2K?
Who is it?
Timber World, thank you for the 2000.
doing my part oh my god we're almost there we're literally
we're literally 5k 5k we're in the oil barons it's time
Timberwealth the god 2000 holy shit cast cast cast i can't
believe we're doing it do it do it do it it's for charity
come on you know you want to but also have enough money for
food though please don't force yourself to donate please
don't please guys guys guys no matter what please look after
yourself first and foremost chat i mean please look after
yourself first or foremost please your your your pets need
to eat you need internet to watch me chat you need internet
to watch me your pets need to eat um you you need the
electricity bill you need the water bill your family your
kids education what about your college education oh my god
2k oh my gosh we're so wait faint smile thank you for the 2k
holy shit we're 2 000 left guys 2 000 left you have 10 more
minutes okay 10 minutes tick tock I should play Jeopardy.
Wait, can I get copyrights tried for Jeopardy?
Is there a copyright-free version?
Okay, Jeopardy.
Public.
Public domain.
Domain.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Elevator music.
Public domain.
Free license elevator music.
Let's go.
Oh, wait.
That's Elevator.
music.
I didn't realize.
I felt that was just Schwartz music.
Okay.
Here we go, guys.
We can have this while we wait.
Oh, we hit it.
Congratulations.
We did it.
Guys, we did it.
91,000.
Oh, come on.
We can hit No, I'm joking.
I'm just kidding.
We're not gonna push it.
We're not gonna push it, Chad.
We did it, everybody.
We got your visage.
Full chapters.
You should be proud of all of... You should be so fucking
proud.
Okay, guys.
Alright, alright.
Alright.
You guys want another deal?
If you can do this within eight minutes, guys.
Within eight minutes.
will defeat two bosses in Elden Ring if you hit 100k.
Two minutes.
In eight minutes.
Can you guys do that?
This is all for charity.
I will do it for charity.
Eight minutes left.
If hit 100k, I will play Elden Ring and defeat two bosses
okay if you guys can hit it in okay okay fine if you guys
can hit it in five in eight minutes i'll do five bosses okay
you literally have eight minutes you guys can do it you guys
can do this i will defeat five bosses in elder ring why not
you're not gonna pick the fucking bosses like what
No, we already got, guys, do not worry.
No, no, no, no.
Do not worry.
We have the dad stream, guys.
We have all of that chat.
Like, the auction money goes straight into the stretch
goals.
But I'm giving you guys extra incentives now.
I'm going to give you guys extra.
So, we already got Brood War.
We already got Brood War.
We already got the dad stream.
We already got because we're adding in the auction money in
there So do not worry about that But now, if you guys can
hit 100k on the Tiltify itself On the Tiltify You guys will
get the Elden Ring stream Can we?
Okay, if you guys can do it, if you guys can do it I will
give you five main story bosses I will give you guys five
main story bosses is there we don't have time we don't have
well guys gotta believe in them
wait how many mean story bosses this Elden Ring have wait a
minute Elden Ring main story bosses oh fuck okay okay thank
god there's a lot more than five okay one Okay.
Eldering every boss in order.
Okay.
Let's get one, two, three, four.
That works.
Okay.
That is doable.
It's okay.
Okay.
That is doable.
I can do it.
Okay.
I'll do it.
Everyone's like.
Go.
She's gonna do Elden Ring!
Go, go, go!
I was like, Dragons, we weathered her down!
We did it!
We got everything we wanted, Dragons!
What?
Not... Who donated 4K?
Who did that?
Next scene!
What?
fuck oh my god dexy fucking donated 3k bro oh my god oh my
god hey nice 420 you fucking mad lads you waited you waited
until i offered elden ring you guys all fucking waited until
you heard Elden Ring you guys strike you weathered me down
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha congratulations everybody you all got your Elden Ring and
your massage
but in the end we managed uh they learned to negotiate
better
oh my gosh in the end we all managed to raise so much money
for charity and like honestly that's what matters the most
that's what matters the most i can't believe you guys got it
within eight minutes jesus christ you guys did within like
six minutes Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Yeah, there was like four.
Sorry, not women.
There was like four minutes left and you guys managed to hit
100k.
Just on Tiltify alone.
In total.
If the auction is still going on.
So currently we've raised, including the waiting room
charity.
We raised in total around, I believe.
almost 200k and i think like that's something we should all
be incredibly proud of to be able to raise um 200 000 us
dollars for um uh cause for two caught charity causes
regarding um mental health and both awareness and research
uh thank you everybody thank you again it is amazing um even
you know this is only like a six hour stream we managed to
raise so much money within just six hours and the auction is
still going on so maybe we'll be raising even more money in
the end within when the other side of the world wakes up for
those if they're still they want to bid on anything as well
so um thank you everybody it has been a huge pleasure i'm
really happy that this was the very first event i'm doing
for all of you guys um and uh for a for such a great cause
and uh and yes the tillify will still be oh uh will still be
opened until the auction ends so after the auction ends we
will calculate everything together um but thank you
everybody i hope you guys a last shout out to all the
creators that worked incredibly hard um uh with uh my
manager and Mr. Man and Little Man and getting all the
auctions auction stuff done as well as Tiltify and the
Foundation for working with us and giving me access to the
auction house and as well as you dragoons of course we could
have done it without you dragoons guys with a generous heart
about your generosity and your effort and just like hanging
out with me as well letting me being the stream this long
for all you guys you're all amazing and we all did something
really special today thank you everybody i'm gonna call it
here guys uh but thank you all as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys Bye.